Cuz tell me what happened. >> Cuz he's in prison right
now, which is why he's not in your black husband is in prison.
Of course,
[laughter]
[laughter] dude. This This lady got aura. What the [music]
>> Okay. All right. Let's check this out. We'll see. We'll
try to get into it. >> I don't care what race you are.
You're acting like a hard art. >> Your black husband is
in prison. Of course, this has to make sense. >> Okay,
I can see why this video is going to get views. >> Dude,
don't act like it doesn't. I live in the ghetto and I hate all
the Mexicans that work on [laughter] my car >> Good night.
>> You said it, not me. >> Black Lives Matter started
happening and everything was going off. I >> know you don't
like those.
>> Sign up for the new and improved Dollarise budgeting
app. Take the free trial and if you like it, >> shut up,
Caleb. >> Yes, it is. Thanks for coming up from San Antonio.
I really appreciate that. Listen, a part of me is kind of excited
because we never really have people over like mid30s, you know?
It's rare. It's rare. So, that's it's exciting to have someone
closer to middle age. Um, good. I'm glad. I fought really hard
to get on here. Actually, this is like the third time. Were you
like, "Yes, this is the third time." This is the third time to
apply. And if y'all weren't going to accept me, first I wrote
like kind of a thing, then I didn't write anything. Then, I wrote
like an essay. I was ready to give you like a book if you weren't
going to let me on. >> Well, I don't see any of them, but
I appreciate it. What do you do in San Antonio for a living?
>> Um, Jesus.
>> One, Tover. Why are you Why you bring the incel energy
right now? What's going on, man? Are you good? Are you good?
>> I am mainly a swim lesson teacher and swim coach. >> That's
a full-time gig in the summer. Well, I started in May and I'm
stilling teaching and I don't want to be. Um, >> okay.
[laughter] >> But I I in the height of the summer, I work
10 hours a day outdoors at an outdoor pool
>> Yeah. That's it's hot down here for people who don't
know. >> But you're in the pool.
>> Okay. Standing there like waist deep and
>> by the way
[clears throat] if she actually does that for a job and she has
been for a long time that explains why she looks older. Okay.
The sun is your enemy. The sun is what ages you. Stay out of
the sun. It's water kind of, you >> Well, okay. Eagle,
you clearly hate this. Why are you doing this? >> I don't
I I've done it for 20 years. Um
I really enjoy it. Honestly, I work with I I >> does not
sound like it. >> Okay. So, I've done it for 20 years.
Um
I work with people who have a lot of like fear and like I help
them through their fears and like touch on anxieties.
>> I get a lot of people who are super afraid. All ages.
So, um, 18 months all the way to adult. And then the past 5 years,
I've kind of started specializing with like special needs. So,
non-verbal
down syndrome. Um, >> we let them swim. >> Yes. Kids.
Actually, [laughter] >> we love swim. >> I wasn't
talking about the tism ones.
>> the tism ones are the funnest and I get the most like
we catch vibes probably cuz I'm a little
kids. That's nice. But um so I'm um emotionally burnt out on
it because you can imagine it requires a a huge level of patience
to like
be giving all your energy to [sighs] someone who's super afraid
and like possibly like clawing and like climbing up you. I mean
I like physically wrestle with some of them. >> The and
the downs these >> Yeah. The downs tackling the Okay. Especially
the downs we're tackling. If they're if they're super afraid
and they don't want to do something. Yes. Cuz we're doing it
cuz it's saving lives people. It's it's drown proofing people.
So Yes. Yeah. >> Okay. And this is
>> Are you even getting paid for this right now? Cuz it's
entering. >> I also get paid quite well. I get paid um
$40 a lesson. So it's like $80 an hour that I make. >> But
$80 an hour. How many hours a week? Well, 40 hours a week in
in the Well, I start in May and it's usually
>> Oh, she's Dude, that's actually crazy.
Suddenly, this all makes sense why she keeps doing this job.
>> when does it end? >> It used to end in August.
So, in June and July, it's definitely 40 hours a week, but then
in August and May, it was closer to like maybe 20 hours a week.
And then during the rest of the year, um, like I was a stay-at-home
mom or I would just like work like part time. Yes. I have two
kids, >> eight and six. >> Is there a father involved
in this? >> Yes, my husband.
>> Yeah, we've been married for 10 years. >> Oh,
we're calling him Fox. Very good. How old is How old is Fox?
>> He's 38
and I'm 41. Yeah, that's right.
>> Okay. So, what's >> 37? Sorry. What's going on?
What? You're Wait, he's 37. >> He's 37. Sorry about that.
Yeah. >> So, what's going on? What are we talking >> So,
the main issue now and which is why I was trying to get on before
all of this happened. Well, we hate illegals, but my >> She's
going I just want to know. I'm trying to hypothetically in my
head. I'm trying to figure out how she rolls Asian hate into
this. Okay. Indians is easy. We already know she talks about
black people. There's Latinos, illegals. Okay. I just want to
know how is she going to roll Asian people into this in a negative
way.
All right. I'm I'm going to use the bathroom real quick. I'll
be right back. I'm going to hit play. We're listening. We're
listening. >> Husband suggested smuggling them. And so
now we've got to figure this out.
>> Wait. No. What does that even mean?
>> I'm assuming we're talking to illegal
>> Okay. So, okay. You and your husband hate them, but
>> Well, okay. We're we're definitely like we're definitely
smuggling. Most people would consider us like extremist rightwing.
Um I don't know how extreme we actually are, but um we definitely
don't well we definitely don't agree with illegal immigration
and I'm down to
>> ship them back. And I heard some thing that like Trump
is trying to pay illegals to like go back. I think that's a great
idea. I'm not necessarily proTrump. I'm just saying that I think
that's a great idea. Um >> is Trump too far to the left?
>> I think he's an independent. I don't consider him a
Republican. I think he's an independent and he's probably controlled
by his little handlers as all of them are. I I'm more like a
I don't know. I There's There's other people running the show
besides him, but we don't need to get I don't know. I There'slers
as all of them are. I I'm more He's probably controlled by his
little handlers as all of them are. I I'm more like >> Yeah,
I had to be here to hit the song. Okay. The Sometimes the song
needs to happen. I was gone. I couldn't play the song. Okay,
dude. Caleb, I I couldn't see Caleb's facial expressions when
I walked away. I'm glad I can now. Getting a That's about the
vibe I'd expect. Dude, how are you? Like, you are racist. You
think illegal immigration is a massive problem. And one of the
jobs when you're looking for work that you go to is coyote. Really?
You're like a double piece of [__] for that.
Like it's one thing if you're helping people get into the country
because they need to like reconnect with family or they just
want economic opportunities, but you actually think you're hurting
your country by doing the job, but you could do the job anyway.
Wild, man. >> Like I I don't know. I There's There's other
people running the show besides him. But we don't need to get
into Trump and all of that. Like whatever. >> Well, listen.
No, no. I mean, it's interesting cuz you said some people call
me far right, but I don't know if I'd call myself far right.
Um >> Guds, we already know the answer cuz it's in the
preview. Okay. >> Yeah. I'm more moderate, but nowadays
>> moderate on what spectrum? Cuz we've had a lot of far
left. It's about time I have a far right.
>> I mean, it's pretty exciting. >> I mean, my husband's
half black, but he's also kind of like, uh, I think people are
better than black people. >> He says [laughter] black people
are
>> The self-hating black man. Let's go. >> Black
people. Oh, white people are but he he doesn't really have a
racial home because he's he's his mom is white and his dad is
black and he was raised by his dad who is black and um the only
racism he's ever experienced has been actually from black people
because he's not black enough, whatever that means. Okay, because
he talks like some white gamer nerd um who's read like the Warren
>> So, he's kind of the weirdest person you'll ever meet.
Well, answer me this. How often do you drop the hard R?
>> The hard R. >> Oh, you know the hard R. >> Jokes
or what? What is the hard R? >> The N word.
all the time. Like on the daily.
>> Okay. Am I the only one who thinks she's actually joking
when she says that? I feel like that's pretty clearly like a
joke. Maybe she'll
>> double down on that. >> He is one.
>> Okay, that's a little worse. That was a little Hey.
Uh-oh.
>> He would say that we judge everyone based on their >> This
is not true. No, she's not just like me. That's not funny. That's
not >> Character and not their color. But >> I can
appreciate that.
why is there a butt there? We judge people by the content of
the character and not the color of their skin.
We're not necessarily dropping hard Rs though. [laughter] >> Well,
not like to someone's face, but in the privacy of our own home.
Yeah. >> Oh, and to him. >> Well, yeah, but
>> yo, French toast Mafia with five gifties. Let's go.
That puts us where that actually puts another hour on the stream.
God damn.
Big money tonight. Thank you guys very much. Appreciate it. Appreciate
you. Thank you very much. French toast mafia for the five gifties.
Let's go.
>> Okay. I'm still confused by the we hate illegal immigrants
so we tried to smuggle them and that's >> why we're we're
and we're trying to clean things up. >> So he's incredibly
confused too. Um basically this was like a result of
money desperation. Um he has been through a lot of
>> Damn. French Toast Mafia throws another five gifted
in. Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much, French Dose Maf. Really appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you. Thank you. >> We can get into it if you want.
We don't have to. Um, he felt like if I can just get this big
chunk of money, this is going to make up for all this stuff.
Like, we need this. Like, this is going to help us set on the
right foot. Like, at the time, he was just working like a janitor
job at a church for like $10 an hour. And he's like, "If I could
just get some money, like that's going to make up for so much
and all this these bad things that I've done." And so >> things
that I've done, >> right? Well, there's been like substance
abuse stuff and and different things. He's just had a lot of
>> And which half of him did that? >> He's had a
lot of mental health issues. Um, which he's currently working
on. Um, >> that's good. >> Yeah. [clears throat]
I mean, he's not someone who's like a victim mentality. It's
like, no, I did this. I up. And now this sucks because he's like,
"Oh, cuz of greed, I'm going to real quick get like 4,000 bucks
and I'm just going to give these people a ride >> by smuggling."
>> Well, they didn't tell him it was that and it was through
like I don't know. >> Wait, wait, this was already done.
>> Wait, this was done? >> Oh, hold up. >> Yeah.
Wait, how did you not know that? That was She's literally wants
help managing the books from her coyote business. That's what
she said to you. Did Caleb not get it the first time? >> Tell
me. Tell me. >> She said, "Now that this has already happened,
I need help or something." She literally She literally implied
it had already happened. >> Cuz he >> Tell me what
happened. >> Cuz he's in prison right now, which is why
he's not in your black husband is in prison. Of course, [laughter]
Dude, this this lady got aura. What the
She's without missing a beast. Your black husband is in jail.
Of course he is. [laughter] >> Yeah. Yeah. Black daddy's
in jail. Who
>> Dude, [laughter] what the [__] >> Yes.
Yes. Which we've joked about >> Oh, I'm >> And because
in jail um they do it Well, it's actually federal prison. And
because they do it like by race, like you have to have um like
[laughter] Okay, so when you
What is she laughing at? When you go into the prison, they um
like they ask you to be part of a car, which is like who you
ride with. So it's >> who does who asked you that? >> Yeah.
When you're an inmate, all the people come up to you and they're
like, "Hey, dude, like what what car do you want to be in?" And
so it's like the blacks tried to claim him and he was like, "No,
I'm not." And then the whites were like, "Well, >> he doesn't
like, >> bro. I How do you not go with the first people
who draft you in prison?" Okay, you got to go with if they're
willing to accept you, you just got to accept it. Okay. Never
ever ever risk not getting accepted into one of the groups. What
the [__] >> are people? >> Right. Which
is why he was like, "No, >> like this is not my Listen,
Crips, this is not my first choice race. I'm trying to get in
with the Hell's Angels over there. All right, please [__]
off. If I need a If I need a fallback race, I'll come to the
blacks. All right, but I'm trying to go for the whites. Just
give me a second. >> I'm not going to ride with y'all."
Um, and then like the whites were like, "Well, I mean, we're
down with you cuz you're basically a racist, but like you're
black, we can't take you." And so he's the car he's in is called
I think it's like Solana or Solano, which is like you're independent.
And apparently the child have their own car, but they're in their
own separated camp. >> And he's not in that. >> He
is not in that. So you can tell everybody
took >> Dude, when did Caleb Hammer start doing meme edits
on all of his? Has he always done this? I feel like I I've watched
some episodes and it used to just be straight and now there's
like meme edits into his Has it been this way for a long
>> The cars has their own TV at the prison that they that
they are allowed to watch. So it's like the blacks are all in
one corner watching one TV and then the white >> dude.
Spruce Willis. Nah, it's new. Watching it back. He's always been
on it. Trinabite. No, he hasn't. Warp Thing. This is new. Okay.
Couple people are like it. I'm getting different. I'm getting
mixed messages. Actually, it seems like now the memes are there.
>> Lights are over here and the Salanas have their and
I guess the jungle
have their own uh TV at their own camp which is separated. And
then we were joking. It's probably on Disney Channel cuz [laughter]
>> cuz it would be. >> So when did this happen? Operation
Over the Border. >> So he was arrested. Okay. So this was
July of 2024. So last year he was arrested on July 4th. >> It
was during Biden's administration.
>> I I don't know how the politics of it all plays out,
but like basically
Wait, this is her before.
No [__] way.
Hold on. I feel like I can almost see
This is apparently like an old picture of her. But listen, this
is what happens when you're out in the sun all day, okay? This
is what happens. Apparently there's an older picture of her.
Damn, she is hot. But also I feel like I can just about smell
those dreads. Very gross. Okay.
Very gross. Yeah, I can just I Not cool. Not cool, dog. And keep
>> He He is like so
He's like, "What kind of up person am I that I'm going to go
against my own belief system just for like some some money?"
But I guess that's >> Well, you guys self-confessed
hate illegal immigrants. Well, [sighs] hate's a strong word,
but I mean, I'm we're very anti- illegal immigration. If you
want to move here, great. There's all kinds of legal means to
do it. Please do
>> I think everyone likes the legal route. Yeah, sure.
>> Right. So, if you're going to like
come illegally over here and be like, "Oh, no. This is so hard
and they're doing all this mean stuff to me and separating me
from my children." It's >> I think Caleb would let that
go. It's just a little difficult when you guys attempted to illegally
smuggle these people in yourselves. >> Well, you kind of
broke the law. That's why is like um yeah, I'm in here and this
is my own fault. Like there there's no one to feel sorry for
me. Like this is this is what I get cuz this was stupid and now
I'm here. And so that happened last year. Um he was in the holding
tank um for it was basically four illegal immigrants for 2 months.
He got super sick. He actually developed MRSA.
If you don't know what that is, it's like advanced staff infection.
Then they were like, well, if he needs um medical help, like
you're going to have to bail him out. And so he didn't want to
be bailed out. He just wanted to sit there and like serve the
time. So they bailed him out. I bailed him out for $1,200. She
said, "Okay, >> I bailed him out for $1,200."
And then I had to rush him to emergency. >> Dude, is there
usually this much yapping in financial audit? Like
I I don't even know what her finances are like yet.
Far be it for me to tell this guy what the format of his show
is. But like can we get to the balance sheet a little bit? >> These
services in San Antonio and then he had emergency surgery that
lasted for however long he he got better. He started working
and now he the sentencing happened in May of this year and now
he went to jail in August. How long is he in jail? >> He's
going to be in there probably until this summer. The sentence
is 18 months, but it's probably going to be closer to 10 months.
>> Okay, that's not >> Sorry, that was >> oddly
not that crazy for enforcing
>> Well, but it's the the charge I think is conspiracy
technically. >> Yeah. [laughter] Wouldn't it be terrible
if you publicly on a YouTube video admitted to the actual crime?
He got charged for the attempt the the thoughts towards committing
a crime, the conspiracy to commit a crime. You just confirmed
that the crime actually was occurring. No, >> I feel like
that should >> maybe not. Maybe you could argue she's not,
but >> punish a little heavier. >> He didn't cross
any borders. So, they were already in Texas and they were going
from one Texas city to another Texas city, which I think is >> so
he internally smuggled.
>> But no, no, no. The reason I asked that original question
before we went down that and you started explaining your beliefs
a little more, I'm sorry. I'm saying you hate illegal immigrants,
self-confessed.
Yet he got arrested
for
smuggling
them internally. >> Yeah, he went against >> Makes
no sense. And I'm confused. And now we're because of that. >> Yep.
Yep. That doesn't make sense. >> Listen, if Biden's going
to let this happen to America, I might as well profit from it.
I can tell you exactly how these people think. Okay. >> I
know that's like the most pro-life person offering abortions
in their back
>> Yeah. Well, >> like that doesn't make any sense.
I told him not to do it. By the way, this wasn't a secret. Like
he he told me and I was like, "Do not do this. Why are we doing
this?" >> Your husband, you told him not to. And then he
did.
>> yes. He's like, "We just need this money." I'm like,
"But we don't. Not that bad."
>> And then he did it anyway.
Is his money-making opportunities? And I would suggest yes. After
this, what is it? What does he have? Felony. I told him if this
didn't work out that I get the biggest I told you so of my life.
And he's like, "Deal, >> that doesn't pay the bills. >> I
got the biggest I told you [laughter] so of my life." Well, yeah,
you're 100% correct. He's he has a permanent felony on his record.
It can't be um expuned as far as I know. Um I've looked into
it. He's looked into it. Um he has a federal
for the rest of his life now. >> He was smuggling people.
I mean, this >> I I Hey, he I don't want any sympathy and
neither does he. I want solutions to how to fix this. >> Uh,
well, one half of the household not working. One, definitely
not bringing in money right now other than pennies for >> I
was trying to get in before he went in so we could try to make
a plan, but that didn't happen. So, >> I don't know how
we missed you.
>> That's a flaw in the casting system, I'll tell you that.
[laughter] >> They told me there was some issues cuz I
got ghosted. I was like going through the process and then I
like got ghosted and I was very sad. But I'm here now. So
>> So what was he making? You said like 10 bucks an hour.
>> No. Well, okay. >> Sorry. Real quick. I'm like
looking for other stuff. It's just like a grab bag. I'm trying
to figure out what I want to cover for not just the rest of the
night, but >> just looking around for what's going on.
Okay. See if there's anything big going on. I see this clip pop
up. XQC gives his take on Israel.
We had an XQC t I I was like, "Okay, my chat is going to want
to see this. We need to know XQC's position on Israel. I also
don't like the the the anti- like Israeli Israel thing like Oh,
guys, dude. Dude, what what what what the officials and and the
[__] people at the top are doing in a certain country.
Dude, I got what they saying 07 does is is is everybody that
you know that Israel, [laughter]
>> his entire chat's just like, "Good luck, buddy. I think
it's a mistake. Good luck. Good luck. Have a good person." every
some of these guys spawned in America or or or or their parents
brought to America when they were young. Are they all bad people?
No. It's like weird. So why why are you putting in the same pot?
>> Uh they all sweep for the same like mass death event,
the mass casualty event. They'll sweep for it. Sweeping for it's
>> Didn't do anything. They just spawned. >> Pretty
easy to understand. >> Does it mean they're people? No.
But they like aren't to be trusted as like moral arbiters at
all. >> The server is Oh, you you're a bad person because
of things you can't control or I think it's I think it's like
awful. Like dude, I I don't I don't like that. I I don't like
doing that. If you if you continue with this with with this type
of behavior and his line of thinking, then you could do the you
can say the wildest. You can say the >> AI Hosbbor Israel
pours millions into US influence efforts targeting evangelicals
and churches in chat GPT.
I wonder if we got any dumped into
out there. And when you say it, people say, "Dude, that's wild."
Yeah, but you've been you've been saying the same thing about
about Israel, so why not?
>> That's a joke. It's a joke. Don't worry about it. >> Oh,
because the direction of the country's officials and people that
are at the top is bad, then everybody else is bad. Come on, man.
Come on, man. I don't think it's fair for them. I think it's
very unfair. See, he's saying they >> What? Wait, what?
Don't you >> You could do the You can say the wildest You
can I need to I need to focus up and actually listen to him and
not try to meme on him. Okay. >> Server is Oh, you you're
a bad person because of things you can't control. I think it's
I think it's like >> Oh, no. Nobody But hold on. Nobody's
just like mad at people who exist in America and aren't like
trying to
wash away or whitewash like the crimes of the Israeli current
Israeli regime. That's obvious. That's like explicitly what most
people are against.
Yeah.
awful. Like, dude, he's saying, "Oh, if somebody, you know, spawns
in
how could you hold them responsible for all this?" I'm sorry,
I'm trying my best with the accent, right? So, obviously, you
don't want to hold those people responsible. Obviously, if people
are willing to say like, "Yeah, I totally condemn Netanyahu.
Yeah, I totally condemn the military operation, the the want
and death that's happening in Gaza that was happening in Gaza."
Then, yeah, I got no problems with them. I don't know most pe
I don't know a lot of people who do have a problem with them
other than Asthma Goldold's best buddy. Dude, I I don't I don't
like that. I don't like doing that. If you if you continue with
this with with this type of behavior and his line of thinking,
then you could do the you can say the wildest [__]
You can say the wildest [__] out there. And when
you say it say, "Dude, that's wild." Yeah, but you've been you've
been saying the same thing about about Israel, so why not?
If
he's really I listen I can translate XQC most of the time. He
is not saying anything sensical here. He might have an idea right
of what he wants to say.
It's like dude it he is basically saying if you let people talk
this way about Israel then they can say wild that people will
say wild and then all I'll say to you is like you let them say
it about Israel. I think he might be trying to get at the idea
that like
I think sorry I shouldn't be saying like as much. I need to go
back to the Pepe ropes for like. So I think he might be trying
to get at the idea of
if you allow people to to like be bigoted based on identity then
it can easily go over to another identity. It can go to some
group some identity group you belong to and be used against you.
This idea of judging people for their identity is something we
generally don't like.
Right?
So kind of the idea that with the Republicans, they allowed some
bigotry towards certain groups like Latinos, I want to say, under
the oposes of like their immigration policy, they they they'll
risk being
racist to Latino people and not thinking it's that big a deal
because the idea of being uh the idea of being
more harsh on illegal immigration is more important than not
being racist. So So I think that's what he's trying to get at,
but he is not communicating that at all.
Isn't what he's saying also assuming every American supports
Israel's actions right now? No, he's saying that I think he's
saying that people are getting blamed regardless of what they
think.
So, I think he's saying regardless of whether you support Israel
or not, you're getting blamed for those actions.
People in America, I think that's what he's saying. I'm just
doing my best to interpret and understand the other guys. Oh,
because the direction of the country's officials and the people
that are at the top is bad, then everybody's bad. Come on, man.
Come on, man. I don't think it's fair for them. I think it's
very unfair. See, he's saying they support what the government
is doing. Who is they, man? Who is they? There's there is a >> It's
so easy to have this conversation. Don't say they support what
the government's doing. Just say if they support what that government
is doing. And if they care more about that country than America,
then [__] those people. You just condition it. It's
very simple, right? If you believe a certain thing,
not if you were born with certain genes, you if you believe a
certain thing, you super easy. >> A tremendous amount of
of Israeli people, people that are that are that are in the country
or or in America, right, that are very anti what their what their
government is doing. A of a a tremendous amount or >> Yeah,
I got no problem with those people. Who's got a problem with
those people? I know. I know. You'd never catch for all of his
faults. You'd never catch Asmin Gold going, "Yeah, I don't care
if you disavow. I don't care if you disavow Israel, their actions,
Apac, Netanyahu, all of it." You for being You will never catch
Asmin Gold saying that. So, who is he talking about? He's talking
about someone, but I don't know who it is.
Maybe you could you can get there with Fentes. Possibly opposing
what they're going to 100% and these guys are what are you going
to alienate all of them? >> Any welcome to the jungle.
>> Name one. We've seen a bunch of videos and posts about
food. Although apparently there are people in his chat who are
willing to be the foil for this and go, "Oh, actually all the
are bad." And then XQC's like, "No, some of them don't support
it." And he's like, "Well, name name a who doesn't support it."
I don't know. Adam
uh what's his name? Adam
>> Freedelland. Yeah. I Why did I lose the name? I Oh,
cuz I attached Freedelland to friended and I was like, "No, not
Adam and Sitch." Adam Adam Freriedland. Yes. Thank you. protests
that are the top that are free Palestine Palestinian movement
protests and a bunch of like Israelis are are part of those protests.
We we've seen a bunch of it. It's not some propaganda. It It's
real because dude, they don't they don't agree what the government
is doing. What about it?
I will say like I support those people but unfortunately the
support for the Israeli regime and like the overall
state that that country operates in the status quo has to be
like gone right like I I don't support that. I wouldn't support
my country supporting that. Thankfully my country is a civilized
country that has cut off I believe economic ties with Israel
entirely over this. So W although might be restored if there's
a ceasefire. I'm not totally sure. Okay, then you know what,
Ch guys? You know what? Then I'm
I'm going to flip it back on to you then. I think every American
is [__] weird because you guys are American and what
Trump is doing with the ICE raids is [__] crazy.
So if you're American, you should >> Also, yes. >> Feel
bad. You should >> uh Yeah. Yeah. Yep. If you support that,
you should feel bad. Yep. Yep. He Yep. That he's got it. If you
don't support it, if you voted against it, you you advocate for
other people to vote against it. You got nothing to really feel
bad for. You tried your best,
>> You feel bad. >> Super simple. >> And you
are nothing.
Stop typing in the chat if you're American cuz of what
man at top is doing. Dude, come on, bro. Are we pretending that
people aren't just racist to like or you know, bigoted towards
nationalities as a meme online? I certainly see my chat say enough
about Canadians to know that everybody here is okay with making
fun of somebody's nationality. All right, I see this all the
time. Sweatpants freedom right here. 51st state comment. Probably
the 51st one of today, you're not a unique. Okay,
I this happens all the time. I I don't think a lot of people
genuinely believe that if you're or if you're Israeli that you
can't be against like the apartheid that was going on there.
You can't be against if we want to use something else like the
what would you call it like the blockade? The not embargo. I
think they call it blockade usually, right? What what do you
call it? There's a name for it. There's a specific word. I'm
not I haven't hit it yet. The the the the occupation. The occupation,
right? Generally, if you're against the occupation, you've been
against a bunch of this stuff. I got no problem with you. I got
no problem with any of that. Well, that's such a comra as a joke,
but see guys, you guys say true as a joke and I think that's
funny because Yeah. Yeah. True. But at the same time, you don't
apply this as a joke when it comes to other countries. >> Wait,
hold on.
>> Man at top is doing. Dude, come on, bro. >> did
he just say? People don't apply this same thinking to other countries.
>> Such a Come on, bro. You say true as a joke. But see
guys, guys, you guys say true as a joke and I think that's funny
cuz Yeah. Yeah. True. But >> no, wait. Why is XQC pretending
that a whole bunch of people in the world don't hate Trump and
Americans because of like tariffs and a bunch of other? This
guy's decimating the world economy. A whole bunch of people hate
Americans broadly even if they didn't vote for Trump.
What? What the is he saying?
Yes, this could absolutely happen.
>> At the same time, you don't apply this as a joke like
other countries. >> Well, I wish they'd attach time stamps
to some of this stuff cuz I would love to go in and actually
like look at the time stamps, see some [__] stuff
going on, but I can't.
This is rough. Emma Vigland hit with brutal reality check on
MSNBC. This is
I want I need at some point in my lifetime Hutch versus Emma
Vigland is a debate on any topic.
Any topic. I need to see Hutch versus Emma Vigland.
Oh, I need it so badly.
God, it would be so good. She's out of his league. Hutch is getting
pretty big as a political
>> I think Hutch is getting pretty big as a >> It
would probably be bad. Am I Am I a big fan of the direction he's
taking? No, not really. But he is getting pretty big. He's like
getting a lot of views. He's doing pretty good.
Oh, these aren't his current live streams. But >> it would
probably be bad if he >> Hutch is a Okay. What the [__]
I cannot do this with the Austrian painter. No, that would be
weird. Okay. I don't want you guys to feel self-conscious. All
right. All right.
Where was I? I would maybe go look at more of that XQC stuff,
but I I'm not going to go track down his uh the time stamp for
that. Loki Koko said he was like defending Indian-Americans,
then he went on to Israel as well. I I would be interested, but
I'm just I don't want to go spunk through his vault. I have to
look for it.
We got We're We're still on uh We haven't even gotten to the
financial part of financial audit yet. I just took us off on
a side journey. >> Okay. So, he's an electrician's apprentice.
So when he has solid work, which he pretty much has for the past
5 years now with >> he makes before. >> Okay, I will
say though, if XQC was looking at Twitter, that does explain
how he found a lot of people who were willing to just go suck
suck suck. Okay, this there is a lot of that on Twitter. >> That
he's made uh
anywhere from 21 to 24 an hour with >> and well with benefits.
Now, that's going to be interesting to see where he lands after
all this is said and done. >> He can still get hours through
the Texas trade licensing. I don't think the felony will affect
it, but it just depends on what company you're working for. He
still hasn't finished his apprenticeship hours. So, you need
7,000 hours to take the journey. >> Yeah. Oh my god. Remember
about 6 months ago when I was like, "Dude, I don't even get racism
in my Twitter timeline anymore." I did like a month of covering
like Fuentes adjacent content and some stuff around, you know,
far right movements. Bro, my Twitter my Twitter is actually just
it's it's straight up
crazy nowadays. All right. I I don't have the luxury I had before.
I used to stay I mostly didn't really use Twitter. I just tweet
about drama like and specifically like streamer drama. But now
I'm doing like more politics and oh boy. Oh boy.
>> License and he has 5,500. How are you going to pay your
bills now that swimming season's coming to a close? >> Do
swimming lessons in October. >> It's coming to a close.
>> Yes. Okay. Here. Here's my >> You can do some
indoor YMCA. >> I I have another pool that I work out of
that I can do indoor lessons, but I'm so burnt out from wrestling
spurs that like I I I need a break, too. [laughter] >> Did
she really say spurs? >> Dude, that's >> I could
like I could cry thinking about it. I'm so drained from all of
this. >> I'm tired of this, GRANDPA. >> THAT'S TOO
DAMN BAD. >> I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR WAY too long. >> Okay.
Um Well, yeah. I mean, >> and now, but it's like, okay,
well, we've got to pay bills, so like do what you got to do.
And so, that's why I'm still at the pool doing it now. When November
comes, I am going to take a break and I have like some organizing
uh gigs like through different people cuz that's kind of what
I usually do during the year is like a six-year-old.
>> Little and no. >> Just wanted to make sure. >> That'd
be a bit much,
>> That'd be a bit much. >> That'd be a bit much.
Okay. Okay. So, what would you want to do if not
uh tackling down syndrome kids?
>> Um, do you do you like help once you know someone's
an illegal immigrant like like a >> How would you know
that? >> No. No. Once you know someone's like a dreamer,
do you like just let them drown? No one is going to tell me.
Hi, I'm here to swim and I'm a dreamer.
>> but if you found out. >> No, I mean, no. No. I'm
Catholic. We're not allowed to do that. Even if you want to.
You're not allowed to do that. >> Okay. Even if you want
to. Okay. >> Hey, that's being for real. >> Yeah.
No, I appreciate it. I mean, I I have a direct quote from your
>> Oh, boy. Here we go. >> I I actually I lost it.
It was there for a second, but it was like
every single person on your show's a liberal, and I want you
to finally have a normal guest.
>> You're not that guy, pal. Trust me, you're not that
guy. >> Yeah. Yes. I watch a lot of I like I've seen a
lot of episodes. I've even gone to like the first like some of
the first like ones, which is kind of neat. You're a little bit
younger and it's fun. >> So, are you going to stay with
this guy? >> Yeah, 100%.
>> Okay. I I know this sounds like, oh well, he's blacked
down in prison, but it's like he
>> from you. [laughter] >> Well, I'm not saying that.
I'm seeing a lower income, committed felony.
>> He is a great He's a great dad. He was a great provider.
He's He is 100% dedicated to me and the kids. >> How did
he find this job? >> Through some terrible app. I forget
what uh what's through WhatsApp. Through >> through WhatsApp.
There's a change. He found a change. >> Sorry, I'm like
slightly boomer. I don't know. The app called Whatever. >> It's
okay.
>> Yes, that's is that is how he got it. >> So, what
are you bringing in on average on a monthly basis? What can I
put down as your income? Especially now it just headed into the
cold. >> This is what's insane. So, it was at like [sighs]
1,500 per week
and now I don't even know what I'm going to I I have no idea
what I'm going to make. Like I have four jobs where I'm going
to be making.
>> You say he found this on
No,
that's No. >> Like probably $20 an hour and I'll probably
get >> Also, I'm I'm straight up looking at other stuff
in the background. I'm sorry. I am doing that. This video is
like cool. I I don't usually like leeching like this, but also
I just I get notifications sometimes and I have to look into
stuff. Okay, so hold on. on the side window. What I'm looking
at right now is we had this tweet from yesterday. Okay. Sneak
was going at Matt Walsh, right? Matt Walsh. He's like, "I'll
happily debate you. Tell me the time of the place your boss approves
of." Right. And we had this tweet, I think today, actually. Yeah,
this this was a follow-up today. Good boy at Matt Walsh blog.
So, he's just continuing to go after Matt Walsh. Okay. Oh, hold
on.
Get back to work, Matt Walsh. Get back to work. Do not criticize
Israel. >> Oh, yes, sir. Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Ben >> Sorry.
I Every time that comes up, I have to take a look. Matt Walsh
Matt Walsh responded. Okay, there's a That's my docket. Hold
on. Matt Walsh responded
right here. Hey, did you ever complete your side quest or sorry,
your quest to make Haiti great again? We've been waiting for
an update on this. Some people will know the truth about the
beautiful country of Haiti. Sorry, soon people will know the
truth about the beautiful country of Haiti. Bro, I can see the
garbage in the streets. Matt Walsh follows up. I was just informed
that this left the Catholic faith and converted to Islam. An
apostate with a 70 IQ who romanticizes third world
and votes for communists. Other than that, seems like a great
guy. Wait, did he vote for Mani? I thought he voted for SWA.
His IQ is 94. It's been tested actually.
Been tested.
Uh, so somebody follows up. So you're not going to So you're
not allowed to debate him then. Got it.
Wash aiming high. taking a swipe at a 24 year old.
Uh, I think he meant Walsh. Walsh. A shimmy high. Take a swipe
at a 24y old. Now, I believe Sneo responded to this. Give me
a second.Oop.
Stop crying and debate me then. Or just shut the up already.
I don't know if Walsh followed up on this at all. Lots of people
going after Sneo.
I think Sneo is doing a good job. I got one clip of Sneo his
clips channel. He had he had a comment on it on stream. He's
back in Miami. I don't know if you guys caught this.
>> All right. See who goes off on Matt >> Matt Walsh
is a
what he's trying to do is get the audience to think that I'm
a I'm a 70 IQ communist third worldist. If I'm so Matt Walsh,
then ask your dad to debate me. Call up Ben Shapiro and say,
"Please, Daddy, can I debate the guy that I'm so angry at?" And
you know what happened? He probably did. And he said,
hung up. >> Dude, the uh
the Larry Ellison's just catching on. >> Dude, this is
straight up. >> This is chank motion right here.
>> like you're washing your hands instead of rubbing them
together. That was the chank Larry Ellison right there, >> dude.
Chank Chank's a cultural force, isn't he? He just he does something,
it catches on immediately. >> The phone or he's just a
and realizes he's he knows he's on the wrong side of history.
He cannot defend his points. So, he's going to continue to say
that, "Oh, I'm Haitian and I'm a communist." >> Nobody
knows that meme. Everybody here knows that memeist and I'm a
terrorist and I'm I'm an Islamist. Nobody believes this anymore.
People are tired of it. Matt Walsh, shut the up or just debate.
Stop tweeting at me. You're wasting everyone's time. Just like
your boss Ben Shapiro is wasting away eating at this country.
Shut the [__] up or debate. If I'm you would be able
to debate me. If a that I disagreed with said, "Hey, debate me."
I would debate him because it's a it's a 70 IQ. Now everybody
knows that you're disingenuine. You don't mean what you said.
>> That's a little Okay. >> Hey, you can debate.
>> I love punching down >> transgender college students,
but when it comes to the communist Haitian, now you're scared.
What is a woman? Two genders. That's all you can debate is two
genders.
Shut up. You're selling out your country. >> Uh, Sneo is
just correct here, by the way. Like Matt Walsh is pretty cowardly.
He's not really I've never seen Matt Walsh make a good point
ever in my life. He's just like a mouthpiece for certain cultural
issues. Like just to be give the populist take. Not useful.
Just redundant. Totally redundant as a >> You're trying
to say that. Oh, I you know I >> uh not Hold on. Whoa.
I'm kind of yelling. not actually a bad actor for real. Uh he
No, he actually was not a bad actor in Lady Ballers.
He's he's a better actor than he is political pundit. I'm not
joking. He should think about a career change. >> Snake
Catholicism and Christians. Ben Shapiro laughed in front of you
about nuns and about priests being pedophiles, making fun of
Catholicism in front of your [__] face. And what
did your little [__] slave ass do, Matt?
Okay. Okay. You sat there like a good little and did nothing.
But I'm the evil guy destroying Christianity. You're selling
out your country and your people right now talking about the
left. IT'S THE LEFT. IT'S THE TRANSGENDERS.
Do you think do what year do you think it is? You think people
are still talking about transgenders? This is the problem. Transgenders
run the government. Trans pack has 98% of their politicians >> It's
transifs.
No, Matt. It's your boss. Therefore, it's you. You work for them.
You're selling out white people right now. You talking about
the the white the white you put on your flannel shirt. Matt Walsh
every stream puts on his flannel shirt and I got a I just went
fishing. I'm an American and I'm I'm doing something for this
country and talks about transgenders and the left. That's who
killed Charlie Kirk a transgender. That's why the white race
is declining. That's why there's gay pride flags in all the churches
in America. Most of them because of the left. You think that's
the reason why? Was it the left who started Epste's Island? Matt
Walsh. Was it the left who owns Donald Trump? is is Trump. >> Oh,
[__] I was like I thought he was doing a critique
of like the right wing selling out their values um like accepting
a bunch of cultural norms set by the left and the right wing
like totally out and accepting them. But he's actually just saying
the did it all. I believe I I got fooled for a second. I was
like, "Oh, he's making like a pretty sharp critique that I wouldn't
think he'd make." And then it's like, "Oh, no. It's just juice."
Oh, it's just juice. >> Pushing in the chair for the left
is declining. That's why there's gay pride flags in all the churches
in America, most of them. Because of the left, you think that's
the reason why? Was it the left who started Epste's Island, Matt
Walsh? Was it the left who owns Donald Trump? Is is Trump pushing
in the chair for the left or for Netanyahu? Is it the left that's
bombing Iran after they said no new wars? So, just shut the up
already. Now, >> some of those were good points. Some of
those were okay points.
Some of them
too far, a little too zealous. Okay. Who's Ellis? Oh,
have him debate himself. Oh, I hate this person's [__]
the worst. But yes, this is very funny that this is uh Matt Walsh.
Matt Walsh's old blog. Bow before Israel. Unless you're an anti-semite.
Very funny. Very, very, very funny. Anyway,
>> so Matt Walsh versus Sneo. We'll see. I legitimately
don't know what Sneo wants to debate him on, though. I still
haven't seen what what Sneo wants to debate him on at all. Like
>> at least maybe 40 hours from it. Um but I'm like flying
by the seat of my pants because you know I that's another thing.
It's like I want I I've already tried to apply at a bakery I
used to work at and they were like um no. I'm like I have all
this experience like why? And I think I have a pretty good resume.
Um >> when did you work there? >> In 2006.
Hey, uh, bakery that hired me 19 years ago and I worked there
6 months. You want to hire me again? >> Been a while. And
did you call someone when they tried to hand you change? >> I
still think the person to watch is Matt Walsh. Why watching you
back?
Just
Like I think I think to me I'm pretty informed on these issues.
This seems like really ignorant. If you want to make an argument
for why you think it's Matt Walsh, you should go for it. But
I don't know why you would think it's Matt Walsh. Yeah, we can.
>> No, I'm actually a great cashier because I love shooting
the people and I'm very >> We're shooting some of [laughter]
the sketchier ones when they come in. >> I treat everyone
equally as I see them. >> As you see them.
Okay. [laughter]
Now, how you see them, that's a question. Uh, okay. Uh, so what's
so we don't even know what to put for your income right now?
>> No. And I also try to >> bring in income. We just
don't know. I also try to go to because I will make happen because
I've been like this my whole life and I will I will make it happen.
It's not like oh I can't find a job so whatever like no I will
find >> you have a degree [sighs] >> I have 108 credit
hours and no degree. >> Okay. Okay.
>> Bro isn't isn't it 120 credit hours or 160 credit hours?
credit hours from when >> from between the years of 2002
to 2014.
>> Okay. Well, they're all over 10 years old, so they're
not going to be >> which is what I before I came last week,
I tried to look into this to see if okay, is there a few classes
I could take to try to get an associates to try to like I don't
know. >> I want to see I see a lot of people my age who
have no idea what they're going to do in 20 years.
Uh yeah, I think that's broadly what causes existential dread
all across America right now. A lot of people getting laid off,
a lot of job, a lot of industries like totally disappearing and
people don't know where they're going to >> Oh, at least
have that. And I I actually was going to do the course careers
like >> I'll get you one for free. Yeah. >> Well,
I was going to do it without you and then I was like, "Oh my
god, it's $500. Like what if >> that's why I don't understand
streamers who like retire and they're like, I don't I just don't
really like this. I'm going to go back to the workforce." like
uh Mr. Moot. When Mr. Mootin did that, I was like, "Wait, what
skills do you have to go back to the workforce with?" What are
you doing to go What are you going back to the workforce for?
This is like your only marketable skill. What are you doing?
Go stream.
>> If this doesn't work, then I've just like wasted 500
bucks. But yeah, >> I Yeah. >> Well, it's not a waste.
It's continued >> I just don't want to make I don't want
to make another bad decision. Like I >> Jesus Christ. I
want to make sure that whatever I'm like moving forward is actually
going to like pay off because if I go to school and want to study
like lesbian dance, like that's amazing. But babe, you're not
>> haircut. [laughter] >> I think I do look like
a lesbian. I really hate my hair right now. >> I had to
cut it off cuz of all the >> Oh, that's not good. >> I
know. >> you can call me a lesbian all you want. It's fine.
Um, >> thank you, dude.
Look, private student loans can make you feel like you're one
mispayment away from selling your >> I don't know. Dropping
out of school, >> You said another mistake. What was the
mistake that you're saying? >> I don't know. Dropping out
of school the multiple times that I dropped out. Did >> But
I stayed focused. I focused up >> No, I was like taking
bong rips and likeing
partying until I was like 30 and then it's like, oh well now
>> it's interesting. You look like HOA lesbian, head of
HOA, but you
uh just partied, smoked, dropped out, didn't take school seriously.
So, you seem like the furthest left
>> person ever, but then you have positions
>> the right as well. You are you are hard to place into
it. >> I'm all I You can't I'm all over the place. I'm
an ex-hippie. I used to have like dreads and hairy armpits. I've
been to like 10 Rainbow G. I you know I watch this financial
audit and I'm just like
he was not the guy to deliver the message. Okay,
but maybe just maybe
Vake might have had a point. Okay, there might have been a little
pearl of wisdom in what Vav had to say about American culture.
All right, I hate to say it. He was not the guy to give that
message. He was not the guy to deliver it. But holy >> gatherings
like I was the most leftleaning person you probably ever >> What
changed?
>> 2016 came and everyone was like if you don't hate Trump
you're like the devil. And I'm like I don't I don't care about
Trump. He's probably like
who cares? Like I don't even know. >> A lot of people care
about politics. >> I don't even know what his policies
are. So I'm not just
>> which vague statement I said about American culture
tourniquet. You don't know the tweet. He's pretty famous. Kind
of blew up his career as a political >> I'm not gonna But
all the people who were talking Yeah. blind hate stupid blind
hate. >> Blind hate stupid. >> And I wouldn't buy
into the blind hate. And so it's like, "Oh my gosh." And they
like started slowly like separating. Well, there was other It
was just like, "Hey, we're married and we have a kid." Oh, you
can't come to the bar? No, dude. We have a newborn. Like, what
do you mean I can't go to the bar? And like, "Oh, we have a house
show this weekend." Great. We won't be there. Like, we're adults
now. Um, and so then like Black Lives Matter started happening
and everything was going off the rail. >> I know you don't
like those.
>> Okay. Okay. >> I'm sorry. That's the whole thing
is and who is black also thinks it's
>> went way too woke. I think everyone agrees on that.
We've come back to a normal place. Absolutely. So, but in the
middle of when everyone was going work woke and if you weren't
woke, you were basically like some mean terrible every hate word
person. >> Well, no one no one takes those people seriously
anymore. >> I was never buying into Okay, but it's it took
10 years. >> Five 2020 to >> uh you have to get criticized
by people and change every opinion. Okay,
it's pretty easy.
Hey, I really hate this Trump guy. Don't you hate this Trump
guy? No, not really.
Um, oh, you're a terrible person. Cool. I think the opposite
of you now. You just call me bad. You >> okay? It it was
happening before.
Sure. But like the ultra like >> just like someone if they
don't fully
I watched it happening and right and so the whole time I've been
like no. And then of course co and it's like all the people I
was friends with were like punk rockers with like spikes on their
jacket and all of that anti-establishment blah blah blah blah
blah. And then it's like the government >> who watch
who do I watch? >> Are you an Alex Jones girly Nick >> Oh,
Alex Jones
is like uncle. >> What the was that camera angle? >> Alex
Jones. We all love him. We've known him forever. You can only
take half of what he says. I mean, you know, like you
>> nickname drop.
Listen, he's everywhere right now. It's just something we all
have to deal with. Okay. Hassan went more destiny.
>> Oh, destiny god. Now >> then you got >> that's
the general reaction. Yeah.
>> Charlie didn't react that way to Alex Jones. Didn't
react that way to Nick Fentes. Didn't react that way to Hassan.
>> Please don't insult me. >> No. No. Your trajectory.
Your trajectory. And now you've gone >> Charlie as well.
Gross. really like >> make us well you know
[clears throat] >> dude dude
oh dude dude it's so it's so over it's so over >> victory
and now you've gone >> just watch watch the reaction point
well you know you did the >> you know
she if she had hair if she hadn't had to cut her hair off from
the chlorine in it from doing the swimming lessons all right
she would have done the hair flip right there absolutely You
did the full spectrum.
[gasps] >> Nick Fuentes, >> you're stuck with me
in the better here. >> A Nick Fuentes guy, but um part
of his >> I don't think Nick Fentes would be uh a fan of
Fox.
>> Actually, I don't really know what
>> Uh yeah, he would. What are you talking >> He
did the full spectrum. >> Did she just say her husband
was is Fox her husband? >> Nick Fuentes. >> You're
stuck with me in the It's better here. is a Nick Fuentes guy.
But um
>> I feel like she was saying that her husband's a Nick
Fuentes guy and then Caleb's like, "Well, I don't know if Nick
Fuentes would be into him." Why? They're the same race mixup.
>> Part of his >> I don't think Nick Fentes would
be a fan of Fox.
>> Actually, I don't really know. Would he? >> Fox
is like Nick Fentes's core demographic. What the [__]
is Caleb talking about? >> No, he's not. He hates all of
it
>> Okay. Actually, because I really don't know. which is
more where I have always stood is like but anyways you have all
these people who are like the man and then it's like the man
is telling you to do XYZ and they're like okay it's like I thought
you guys were like anti- politics and antithe
and the punks like just doing whatever the government said it
just seemed very hypocritical it got very politicized well right
but doing but they took the
>> side of the
like basically the people who are progovern which never made.
So anyways, it was this huge falling out. I don't even remember
where we are in the >> I don't know. I'm trying to loop
this back to money, but also you're very
>> watching you go down rabbit holes is very enjoyable.
>> Oh, good.
>> all right. Well, >> I think >> so. Oh, yeah.
>> You should just start your own show. >> Maybe
that's my new career. Um, however, I'm not delusional thinking
like I'm going to be a YouTuber and next year I'll have like
$70,000. It's like, okay, I don't even know what
Dude, I I see so many people getting like into this right now.
They think this is like where it is. Dude, I
I feel like everybody should go away from this if you're not
used to doing this. It's like it's actually tough.
You know what I mean? Like, not that it's a hard job. I'm saying
that it's tough to get started and you kind of need a leg up
that like it's getting saturated >> to say your income
is >> we still don't know like we >> I have even
note that you heavily rely on your mother. Isn't that kind of
what you've like >> if you've gone far to the right isn't
>> kind of anti
>> far to the right. >> Yes. We don't like it and
I don't like it. We would like to grow to be completely independent.
You're in your 40s. Like, >> What the is taking so long?
>> Oh, well, you know,
>> Pot is not a good idea, children. >> Come on,
man. >> Um, do not >> What do you mean? Are you still
blazing it up endlessly? >> No, I Well, I've only been
sober for
two or three years to be honest. Yeah.
>> listen, more negative studies have come out against
it these past few years, but not to the extent you're trying.
You're making it sound like it's not like that. It's fine if
you want to like be a responsible person and like smoke a joint
on the weekend and have a nice time. But like if you're like
15 and you're smoking every day and then you go into college
and think you're going to be successful and you're just going
to like smoke a pound of a week and do whatever. And by the way,
the now is nuts. You might as well be tripping acid. It's not
like >> THC has massively >> crazy. So we now is
like I don't even know. Um, so thinking you're going to be a
functioning human being because I'm I have to smoke for my depression
like five times a day. Like that's not gonna happen people. >> Okay.
[laughter] I would love to be able to put down an income number.
Uh, >> it's [laughter]
>> He's trying to get like the first number that they're
trying to do, right? He's trying to get the first number. >> What
do I say? 3,000 a month. >> No, I would say closer to 1,500.
Yeah. Unless I can. >> How can you survive off of that
with two >> Uh, credit cards is going to get me to February
and then we're going to get the tax return which will get me
to May when I can start and also in and also in February I can
start group lessons again at the indoor pool and that's going
to get me a little bit of income too and I'm willing to find
another job. I tried to apply at TOA. I thought this was going
to be great. I have it TOA. It's the boot store. >> Oh,
TOVA.
>> TOVA. They've been a sponsor. Come back. >> Uh
oh. I Oh, I saw that. I saw that one where you sponsor. I thought,
ooh,
>> dude, there's again I just sometimes I'm like, dude,
I've got I I I'm not going in the right direction in life. Like
I I should be
I feel like sometimes I'm like if I'm not retired by 40, I'm
like I've totally [__] up my life. That's like my
bar basically. Okay. And sometimes it's like a little questionable
if I'm on track for that. And
that's like my bar for where I'm like, "Oh, I've totally
up everything."
And then I see people like this and I'm like, "Holy shit."
Like, "Holy
shit." Uh, not if you're not there, by the way. I That's me.
Um, I had like tech jobs at like the exact perfect time. I think
if id played my cards right with jobs, if I'd been more like
ambitious with finding new jobs and stuff, I probably could have
retired at 40 quite easily. I probably could have been close
to semi-retired now,
but um so I just look at it that way cuz I've got a couple friends
who are like basically retired now. So I like compare myself
to like my friends in some ways, but um
what do you do if you retire at 40 to 70 if you retire early?
Oh, you just do like this. I can still do this job, right? So
I just I'm like, "Oh, I I like misplayed by cars." So that's
like the bar I compare myself to. And then I see people like
this and I'm like, "Holy [__] Oh, holy. Um,
I love him, too. And my friend works there and she's a manager
and I thought it was an end. [gasps] >> No, cuz I'm sorry.
We just went with someone who had experience. I'm like, I will
work harder than three Gen Z's that you hire if you give me the
job. And they're like, >> can you bend over? >> Hey
yo, >> that's [laughter] funny.
>> I'm a little stiff, but yeah, I I do I've done personal
organizing. I've um for like businesses and stuff. >> Yeah.
You organize people by race as you're walking down the street.
>> Oh my god. >> To see if you're going to cross
or not. >> For your safety, maybe you should. Dude, if
I see some shady black dude on the other side of the street,
I'm not going to run his way. >> Oh, that's cool.
>> Especially if you're in Chicago.
We were talking about that earlier. Kind
>> Well, we were just talking about Chicago. And >> who?
I wasn't here. >> No, you weren't. your cup of coffee that
took like 40 minutes to make. >> I know. It was annoying.
It was >> okay. That was crazy. Did you buy that coffee?
You're okay. >> Yes, I did. Cuz cuz everyone drank the
coffee here. >> I made my coffee at home this morning.
So good. I've never been so lost in a conversation. Okay. I'll
say 1,500 and then in the peak of the summer. What's your monthly?
range it
>> Okay. 30 [laughter] minutes to get that to to get the
income.
Wow. You've been a forer before. >> That was only for a
month and that was when I was like 19. >> Oh yeah. I don't
know if I can get back into that actually. I mean there's going
to be some people. This is going to be a very selective group
of clubs and >> Um dude, there I
uh I didn't realize what he was saying until there are some people.
It's a very selective group of clubs and people. Stripper was
the title. That was the job title that she had before. Stripper.
Hey, you could listen. There's a very select group of people
that would pay for who?
Who? What?
Bro, also I think Caleb should go ahead and stop suggesting
work for people. Okay, you already had your controversy, Caleb.
Shut the [__] up. Hey, Caleb, you got a very successful
channel here. Stop suggesting work to random people. How about
that?
>> First of all, I didn't make any money because I'm not
a scammer. You got to be a scammer to be making money at that.
What was the controversy? He suggested to some dude that he do
gay and like suggest he could connect him with Only Fans and
then there was some Yeah, there was a review on Caleb a little
while back. He was like suggesting Only Fans to some dude and
then he he might have connected him with somebody and then there
might have been some kind of like assault that happened or like
harassment that happened and he kind of blamed Caleb for it and
Caleb also had like some slightly flirty DMs with him I think.
I think, but I don't remember for sure. It was just like it was
weird. It was weird how it went down. We should find somebody
who summarizes it or something. I think. >> And second
of all, it's just I can't >> um I was >> Have you
seen me? I'm awkward. I'm not like a graceful pretty like >> You
don't seem awkward. You seem very confident in everything. >> I'm
like a giraffe trying to run physically is what I'm talking about.
>> Okay. Now, listen. said, "I was about to ask for your
living situation cuz I want to know how you're paying rent here."
But I just also looked at a direct >> There was some flashing
element to that story. Oh, I do not remember that cuz I guess
you've just had so many to cult that he's just feeding them all
to me. That uh I live in the ghetto and I hate all the Mexicans
that work on my car
>> Good night. Okay. Those >> You said it, not me.
I don't [laughter]
>> Those Mexicans do not work on my car. And there are
it it's a it's a Hispanic >> San Antonio, >> right?
It's a Hispanic neighborhood. That's fine. >> It's a Hispanic
city, >> right? That's fine. Fine with it. But there are
levels of Mexican. >> Please take us down those levels.
>> There's tons of like Hispanic families that are just
like nice Hispanic families. They've been there forever. It's
whatever that it's fine. It's everyone's different culture, right?
Just like how white people like I'm German, so I have like a
culture that goes along with that. I'm sure you are. Now there's
like the car shop that's next door to >> Okay. I Caleb's
like not
wrong in some ways. Okay. But
he's he's picking all of the lowest hanging fruit in the world.
Bro hasn't made a single like funny witty comment. It's just
all of the lowest hanging fruit. Now, as somebody who specializes
in picking low hanging fruit, I shouldn't really denigrate him
for this, but come on, man. Come on.
through us. That's like definitely half >> aspire to something
greater. You got 2.6 million subs. >> Illegals where they
sell drugs out of there. They have people living out of there.
They have grown men going behind the building and taking a in
front of my living room window where my kids can see. That is
okay. Pause.
I'll be right back. >> A few moments later. >> File
in line up behind me, lads. with me. Let's do it. >> With
me are all
>> nice Hispanic
American people.
>> Okay. Caleb Hammer. Is Caleb Hispanic, >> I'm
all in. >> I'm going to file on in. >> I've been
a minority in San Antonio for my entire life. >> I'm very
sorry to hear that. I would like you to rank from the worst Mexican
to the best Mexican. You could ask a few questions. Feel free.
And then you can you can rank from the your least favorite to
your favorite. Want to know a dirty little secret? >> Wait,
what the [__] is starting only? >> Hold on.
What the [__] is red
red true tide? [__] is that?
>> You're not broke because you suck with money. You just
can't see where it's >> Stop, Caleb.
>> Oh, what does? >> It's ompic on crack.
>> The [__] beast mean? [laughter] >> Oh.
Oh,
>> I'm sorry.
>> Yes. Yes. So, only one of y'all is divorced. Okay. Boom.
He's loser. >> So, [snorts] Mexican down there. >> Down
here. Down here. Down here. >> Very good. Keep going. Keep
going. >> Now, of the ones left, do y'all all speak Spanish?
>> Raise your hand if you speak Spanish >> No, I'm
one of the good ones. >> No, that means you're a bad one.
You're bad on your cult. You don't speak both. Is he in? >> Uh,
okay. Everybody gets this intrinsically on some level. Okay.
If someone's willing to their own ethnicity, they're a loser.
Okay. Just like her husband actually in front of
>> No, no. You're the worst cuz they're divorced. Then
>> this is my weird criteria. But in >> I didn't
realize she was doing Caleb. Caleb watched that panel at TwitchCon.
He was like, "Oh, you think this is racist? Watch what I do next."
>> Not speak Spanish. That's bad. >> Ask another
question. >> I thought you were going to be a fan of that
if we're being honest. >> Oh, wait, wait. Uh,
>> who can change a tire? Can you change a
>> Bad Mexican.
>> You can't. >> You don't even drive a license.
>> I hitchhike. >> What were your grades in high
school? >> What were your grades in high school? >> Okay.
What's your job? >> I'm an editor. >> What's your
job? >> I'm his boss. Well, you get to be above him, I
guess. And so you'd just be the >> He cheated on his girlfriend.
>> I did not.
>> But that was high school. >> We'll let that slip.
>> But it was for his wife. >> My wife. >> Oh,
you're married. >> Yeah. But once again, >> Yeah.
He's the best one. >> But he's reproducing. >> He's
the best one. >> You want them reproducing?
>> Yeah. If you're a nice
>> Yes. Eagle. >> See, he gets it. >> Look
at him. Look how nice he looks.
>> What do you mean by that? >> He does. He's He's
clean shaven. love the >> I feel like she's just doing
a scop to make everybody hate this guy. She's like, "That's the
guy. I'm going to ruin that guy's life." She's just going to
talk about how much better he is than every one of his co-workers.
And they're going to secretly hate him for being the preferred
the Aryan approved. Okay. Mexican guy. >> Black San Antonio
black I represent. >> And then before they leave, who's
the >> Just by looks. [laughter] >> That's You're
making me do that. >> You don't have to do anything you
don't want to do. I was going down your path. >> No, I'm
not going >> No, you're not going down her path. Caleb
is clearly farming this woman, trying to get her to say the most
egregious racist he can for content. Is he talking about him
going down your path? She didn't ask. Could you bring in all
of your Mexican employees so I can rank them? She didn't say
that. You You had a fit of inspiration. You had a moment of inspiration
yourself. Okay, that's you. That's all you, Caleb, >> doing
that. >> Okay. Thank you. >> Thank [laughter] you.
Gracias.
>> I love that.
>> Okay, so this house that you live in with all the scary
Mexicans around you. >> Scary Mexicans being >> How
are you affording this house? >> Okay. Um,
in our neighborhood, he gunshots like at least uh once every
two months. >> But still, how are you affording the >> Okay.
[groaning] M it is my parents' property that they actually bought
for me cuz they got tired of paying the rent on my apartments
and they got it for super cheap is >> bro her How does
Caleb always find How did Caleb's producer not Caleb's about
to go fire like half of those Mexicans that were just on the
stream because this lady's been trying to get on for months and
months and months and he hasn't gotten her yet.
And this is like his bread and butter when it's like somebody
who is totally pampered. When it's somebody who has no idea of
reality, like like literally this person has had their parents
pay for like everything until they're 40 and they're also like
complaining about, you know, they do crimes. They have no idea
where like she's like, "Oh yeah, I work like 3 months as a swimming
instructor. That's pretty good. That's pretty good money. $1,500
a month she's going to live on." Dude, this is like Caleb
right here. And they didn't get her on. Took them months to find
her and filter her in. >> $60,000 house in 2006
and it had a brand new roof, brand new windows, leveled. >> What
the are you doing? They bought >> also she's racist cuz
they were afraid of paying they hated paying for your >> My
stepdad thought it would be a good investment and then he was
like by the way if can't do her life which happens all the time
she could live there. And my mom's like no. Okay, fine. >> This
doesn't make any sense though. >> So the house is paid
off so I live there. Stereotypically, this is not a one-sizefits-all,
but stereotypically, personal responsibility tends to lean more
right than it does left. Obviously, there's people on the left
that believe in it. There's people on the right that don't. Whatever.
Okay, but even still, stereotypically, that is where it typically
lands. If you are all the way over here on my right, >> I
know >> this makes no sense. Your parents buying a house
cuz they're I'm sick of being >> This was
a long time ago. This was in 2006 or seven and now we're in 2025.
So, I've got to I'm trying to catch up. I'm trying to catch myself
up to where I want to be. >> But you're getting a hand
out. Jesus. >> I know. >> A handout. >> It's
in Well, in jail and I can't pay rent, but even before he was
in jail, we were kind of not paying rent because he was like
I don't know. He had mental health stuff. >> So, what are
you supposed to pay to your >> Uh, it's supposed to be
800 a month. >> I don't know how you do that on 15. >> We're
keeping food and utilities.
>> I don't know how you do that in your budget. I don't.
I literally just don't pay them. >> Okay. And they're okay
with it. Yeah, cuz the house is paid off. There's no >> But
still, they're
not that's not how that works.
>> Yes, but it's like I'm not okay with it. I'm not okay
with it. >> Do they Do they like Do you at least keep the
house up? I hope Caleb minds that. Do you at least keep the house
up? Like do you guys do renovations? Have you been keeping everything
like clean? Keeping everything up like I don't know. Like just
the upkeep in the house. Are you guys doing a good job of that?
Okay. Now, you say you're applying to a lot of jobs, but I highly
>> not really to be real with you. I applied [laughter]
>> I Okay. Well, I'm obviously like a
person who's willing to work and I'm like enough put together
and I've had enough jobs where it's like, bro, I need something
that's like decent. Like, I need to make probably at least 15
an hour, which I think is reasonable. And I [sighs] I don't know.
I I need I have skills. I have skills. >> Why' you Why'd
you try to be a stripper? Why'd you choose that one? That isn't
That's not a skill building thing. >> That was such a long
time ago. >> But why'd you choose it? >> Well, cuz
my friend's
boyfriend's sis.
>> I'm told it's because of a kink. >> Some No, some
freaking >> Colton says it's because >> someone I
was staying with was friends with a stripper and she's like,
"You could come to work with me. It'd be so easy." And I was
like, "I don't know. I have like hairy armpits." And she's like,
"No, guys, go for that." And so I was like, "The little dreddy
girl with like armpit hair." It didn't work out, >> Good.
It didn't work out to ask about your kink because this is >> Wait,
why did she put her kink in her application for financial audit?
I mean, obviously a stroke of genius that I could never accomplish,
but I just don't understand how or why this is coming up or how
his producer knows about it, how he knows about it. >> Financial.
No, that was a misunderstanding and I do not have a
>> I was so truthful on the phone. Don't >> I think
what I'm [laughter]
>> She brought it up on the phone. She's literally saying
do not reveal this. So I from Caleb's face, his actions, everything
about him right now. He's like we're going with this and you're
going to push it out there no matter what. I feel like I feel
like we're going to hear about it.
>> Bad guys. He was saying that men there would have the
king. So I went and
that's what I was told. And so then I tried to go to the strip
club owner said that you were too nasty >> basically. Yeah.
>> Do you have a picture of you back then that we can put
on screen? Can I see it? >> I don't have it. But like >> really
like anywhere. You don't have a picture on your phone? >> I
do, but like I can I like email it to I'll email it to you. >> Of
course. >> I'll send it. You'll be like what the >> Yeah,
let's see it. We'll put it on screen. Cute little dreddy girl.
Flowers and beads in my hair and yeah.
Anyways,
>> But this makes you also moved to Mexico when you were
younger. This is such a I keep wanting to get into the finances,
but this is insane. And you hate them and it's just like But
you live there. >> I'm so confused. >> I only hate
the dirty ones. >> And what percentage is that? >> Well,
I mean, I don't know, honestly. >> Okay. It's not the majority.
It's definitely the minority.
No, we we went to Mexico. Obviously, I don't hate Mexicans, by
the way. I love Mexican >> Nobody ever ever ever ever
point out the existence of this woman to Myron Gaines or Andrew
Wilson. Please stop. Don't do >> Food. By the way, I am
friends with Mexicans.
[laughter] >> By the way, my ex was a Mexican. >> You
just pulled the I have a Mexican >> Well, I hate black
people, but my husband's black. Dude, what the >> Just
kidding. I really don't. Please. >> Okay, she's
She's pretty funny. Okay, she's pretty >> My gosh. >> I'm
not racist. I go to Taco Tuesday. >> I Oh my gosh. If one
of my clients sees >> I like Oh my [sighs] gosh. >> I
don't clients have towns. I don't >> She's kind of funny.
>> I don't [laughter] I don't hate black
>> I do not. >> Not all of us have to say that in
our daily lives.
What's your finance score? 0 to 10.
>> Two. Okay. If you want your hammer financial score,
go to caleb hhammer.com. See where you stand in the world of
finances, where you need to improve, and where you're already
doing well, and what you need to do to fix it. And what's your
racist score? 0 to 10. >> I don't think I could use that
excuse. >> Zero being not race at all. 10 being hyper racist.
>> 10 is like you want the racist to be segregated again
and living in separate >> Executed. Yeah. >> Oh,
so nine would nine or eight would be below that. Um Oh, I'm only
like a >> three maybe. >> If you want your racist
score, go to
See where you stand in the world of racism. If you're not racist
enough or you're a little too racist, find out. >> I took
the lesbian test. I'm like 36% lesbian from your website.
>> I know. >> They have like a lesbian. What? Is
this a joke? >> Uh yeah. Moving to Mexico. Yeah. Our friends
went down there. So, we lived in Chiapas, which is like the southernmost
point in Mexico, like right before
>> I can't hate him that much. >> Let me get into
these numbers for sake. You got two children.
>> And they are very well behaved.
>> I should say guys, uh, we are 10 subs. I listen, we
already going 8 hours. I put 75 to go to 9 hours cuz I don't
necessarily want to stream all night.
yeah, if you guys can hit if you guys can hit 10 more subs, we
could do another hour. >> Some of the Well, >> I've
got we I mean, we'll finish this probably no matter what. Yeah,
I think we'll finish this no matter what. And then
I've got some other I've got other kicking around. >> Well,
I know some of the people on this show are like, I can't tell
my kids and I buy that. And no, I'm like, baby, we don't have
money for that right now because mommy >> and into Okay.
Well, I'm glad. Well, okay. Do you say it like that? >> No.
Nicer and more child appropriate. >> What do you consider
child appropriate? >> Now, remember, I work with kids,
so I know child appropriate. >> Are you a gentle parenting
person or a >> God? No.
>> God, no.
Like, basically, now here's something. Good black people, they
will they will get on their kids. the crazy black people like
at you will see >> like where >> like at Walmart
you will see kids going up and down the aisles and the parents
like whatever whatever and uh Fox is like mortified
>> and I am too because like control your freaking kids
dude.
>> Well, I'm sorry. You go to the white side of town, you
do not see that. >> Come on, dude. >> You see them
screaming in the carts begging for toys, but you don't see them
running up and down the aisles.
Well, I have
>> you'll be very happy to know food stamps are currently
on hold due to the government shutdown. >> So, if you go
to Walmart, I think you'll be happy. >> And who do you
see on TikTok and all of that who are like they're taking my
food stamps and guess what? I'm going to go in there and I'm
going to steal from the store blah blah. I don't know. You tell
me. Who do you see? I don't know. >> Uh she's telling on
her algorithm right now like she's telling on herself completely.
Good times. Good times. >> I'm not looking. Mhm. I don't
know. I don't know.
There's a larger percentage of people who are acting that way
and a smaller percentage of people who are still acting that
way. You can be a hard are dependent upon your race,
not dependent upon. [laughter] >> This is not a confusing
subject by the >> Yeah. There's like white people who are
like acting like hard.
>> That's a very Nick Fuentes concept by the way. That's
true, dude. >> Bro, I do. Okay, don't connect this woman
to Myron or Andrew Wilson. Do connect this woman to Nick Fentes.
Might be the best chance. Okay, the best chance America has to
avoid a Nick Fentes takeover of the Republican party is for him
to see that this woman views his content and is like, "This guy's
got some great ideas. He might himself." Okay, that's the only
shot you guys got. I'm going to be real with you. Okay, it's
your best chance. Please send clips of this woman to Nick immediately.
I'm from the depths of the internet
>> at 41. >> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, that's I hope I
still am, I guess. Uh, but I guess I don't go that that uh >> Nick
doesn't hate his audience enough. Okay. Nick does not hate his
audience >> Deep.
I mean, I filmed with someone yesterday who is racist to uh or
she hated quote Arabians. How do you feel about the Arabians
was her words? Well, in those countries, they have higher percentages
of
and all of the countries that have allowed in uh those immigrations,
all of a sudden they're like stabbing statistics are like skyrocketing,
that's just that's facts. That's not my opinion. That's just
numbers. So,
anyone who says that like the we should love Islam and the Middle
Have you been to the Middle East, women don't drive? I mean,
I haven't either, but it's like women don't drive. Women aren't
allowed to read there. That's okay. I don't know if I I I don't
>> That's okay.
>> no. Obviously, they have not caught up to the 21st century
people who were like, "Love Islam and welcome them in and everything."
It's like once again, if you're going to go through the legal
system, it's part of the law. Anyone is allowed to be here. But,
um, in these countries where they've just opened the floodgates
for anyone to come, it it hasn't gone good for them. So, I'm
not racist towards anyone. Now, if you're acting like a hard
>> where what are those countries? Like Germany is is Germany
the example? I don't even know what country she's talking about.
>> I don't care what race you are. You're acting like a
hard R.
This has to make sense, dude. Don't act like it doesn't. All right,
listen here. Financial audit. I have curated the exact resources
and tools I personally use or would use if I was in certain situations.
So take advantage of these offers in the same exact service states
and it's it's been very hard and there's not a lot of assimilation.
That is very true. But this country does at least pretty well
on assimilation. >> I agree they do. I agree they do. >> No,
the UK >> Well, some people still want to move there. Not
me. >> Well, it's cuz it's still better than a lot of regions,
but it's there was a >> Wait, there was a wood baby trip
to Saudi Arabia. She would have been fine, I'm sure. >> Compared
to here. >> I'm very comfy in Texas with my Mexicans. I'll
take it any day. >> It's not the hards. >> Got it.
>> okay. [laughter] USAA. >> She's genuinely got
like good timing with the with the jokes. Okay. She's actually
got good timing with it.
>> What's going on with this USAA card? >> Uh, okay.
That one was actually started as a credit transfer, balance transfer
>> uh Hold on. Xorm is complaining. Still watching this.
Yeah, we've done like eight different side tracks from this.
That's the stream, bro. We watch some long piece of content,
we get like interruptions and we go off on little side tangents.
That's the stream. That's how it always works. Sometimes takes
us a very long time to move through an hour and a half piece
of content. >> Chase uh maybe last year
cuz I had racked up the chase. Okay, this all began because of
Fox and like job stuff and mental health stuff. And so he's >> that's
another thing we need help on. >> Dude, you just got on
food stamps a couple years ago and you're talking you're talking
people who are on food >> because people are like I'm on
food stamps. I'm like dude don't let anyone know what a embarrassment.
What an embarrassment that I am on it. >> You are on food
stamps but your parents are the government. [__]
are you talking about? Burger is live reacting to tweets. Well
>> I can kind I wouldn't necessarily take it as an embarrassment
of being on >> Well, hold on. Being on a social safety
is there to help. Now, I would be embarrassed as a person if
I was actively trying to not go get more hours cuz I would be
above an income threshold that would qualify for a benefit. I
think if people are actively trying to stay in a benefit, I would
be embarrassed. But if you go through a hard time and you and
you get put on a system that you paid into, that inherently is
not an embarrassment. >> But it's like, how long is the
hard time? And I'm not going to >> depends on the person
in economic >> Well, right. And so it's like, >> but
don't get me wrong, I I vibe with you on the fact that I've had
people on the show that literally will not go get a job because
then they get off benefits like food stamps. That's disgusting.
That's horrible. And obviously we're enabling that. But to say
if you fell on a hard time and you paid into a system and got
support for it, you shouldn't >> What's happening is like
some people fall on a hard time. It's like, oh well, you make
too much and then they like that's happened to someone I know.
>> It's been too long. I think the issue is I should message
Trey and ask her if she wants to cover some stuff at some point.
But um I think the issue is I'm mostly just streaming by myself.
I don't even really join the Discord that much anymore. Like
I don't know how often people look at the Discord and like think
they want to join, but I don't even join the Discord cuz I like
doing at least for political content. I just want to give my
opinion. I don't want to have to deal with like dropins and then
I like get off track. So that's mostly where I am with that stuff.
Sometimes for like this I could just be sitting in the Discord
have people pop in. >> Oh. And so they can't get assistance
and they really should have it. And then there's other people
where it's like ah they're kind of on the fence, but because
they fudge their numbers a little bit, they >> gentle parented
probably. >> Honestly, I'll be honest as someone who's
not a parent and uh you know it won't be for a little bit. I
specifically don't even know what that literally entails on a
literal level, but I hear that you hate gentle parenting. I do.
I do. It means It means that you create a little narcissist.
It's like, "Oh, you're upset. Tell me about that. Okay. Every
Yes. Okay. I'm sorry. I have to go. I have to go because the
four-year-old is pulling me away." That's what that means. >> You
just,
>> right? [laughter] >> Um, excuse me. You're not
the adult and I'm speaking to an adult right now. You need to
wait patiently. >> Okay. Okay.
>> What's the normal minimum monthly payment on this? Normal
payment is like
>> I don't even know because >> purchase 216 on it.
>> 150. I don't know because 150 >> because I've
been paying off so much. So this summer I >> kind of kind
of but you're still purch No, you're still purchasing on this
though. So it's not >> pest control. >> Pest control.
>> Uh well let's see
be on here. >> that's my man. That's my concern. If she's
running down that property that her parents purchased for her,
that's really up. >> I mean that's a lot of pest control.
Well, they come every 3 weeks for the mosquito and we have road.
>> Hey, why was this three times in one week then? A couple
weeks. >> Was it charged all those times? >> Yeah.
53 108 54. >> That's a problem.
>> I'll be calling them as soon as I am done filming because
I'm not okay with >> Also, I think you've had a late fee
this year, I believe. >> Yeah, probably. >> When?
Why? >> Don't know. Don't know. >> I don't know.
>> How do we prevent that in the future? >> Well,
I have it in my phone the bills and all of the dates that they're
due and I make sure. But because and I was keeping up with that,
but then because in the summer I was paying everything. Anytime
I had any extra money, like I'd put a 1,000. I'd put a I'd put
a thousand. So there was no minimum. >> What are we doing
going into this where you have just >> Well, now it's just
now starting cuz like even last week I paid like 500 off on one
of the cards with like all the money that I'm >> automatic
hundreds and hundreds of dollars of bills are going on that offsets
it. Anyway, >> I'm just saying I there might have been
a late fee this month because I'm used to there not being a minimum
monthly payment for the past like four or five >> Yeah.
Well, the deferred it's not deferred interest, but your promotional
balance for the transfer that ends in about 3 months. >> I
know. Which is why I'm trying to quickly pay off the Chase card
because that's where that you have the higher interest. So, USAA
is kind of like on hold because it's the lowest interest rate
and one of the lower payments. I don't even think it's 150. >> This
is the uh this is actually a short with the Caleb Hammer allegations.
Okay, just watch real quick. >> Caleb Hammer. >> How
do you What the are you talking about? One of the biggest financial
YouTubers has gotten into some drama recently. One of his ex
guests said that he assaulted him and kept them captive in his
house. >> He locked me in his house after the second filming.
Essentially, he didn't give me the money until he groped me.
>> And some very strange group chats >> Dude, he's
like 14. I would shove that right down his throat where it belongs.
>> There's a lot more evidence, but is it true? Click this
video to see it's
>> uh I'm not going to click the video. So, I'm just going
to leave the innuendo out there. I assume if it was really true,
if it was like provable, if there was like some actual malfeasants
there that was provable, he would have a rough time doing his
show. You know what I'm saying? I'm guessing he's absolved somehow.
Maybe some offcolor jokes in a group chat. >> I think it's
like under $80. >> No. Yeah, the interest is relatively
low because now Well, yeah, exactly. Because the balance subject
to the interest rate is low, but you have had a late fee this
year which was immediately doubling kind of what was added to
this. >> But when was late? >> He can't see that
on this kind of statement, but it was this year so far. I do
know that. I believe it. I believe >> It's a little concerning
if you're going and shopping for groceries. Walmart is one of
the cheaper places to go. And if that's the place you hate going
to and you're afraid to go. >> Isn't that bad? >> It's
kind of gross there. I only go if I have to really bad. I don't
>> know. He actually did it. Just no one cares. What?
>> I have to, >> dude. No. Why not ATB? Are you kidding
>> I remember covering it and I was like, "Oh, this is
kind of weird." But that was all I could really get to was it
was just like weird. The messages were weird. But I it seems
like I didn't get the whole thing cuz I don't remember the locked
him in a room and groped him. >> Hill Country Fair is nice,
but isn't Walmart brand still the cheapest brand? >> Not
necessarily. I don't think so. >> I think it's comparable
to Hill Country >> Okay. Yeah, HB is pretty good. If we
if we can do HB, we can >> not talk me out of HB. >> No,
I wouldn't. We do our 300 a person uh in that, you know, scales
grocery budget meal plan based on HB. >> Okay. Okay. Well,
then there you have it. No, don't try to talk me into Walmart.
Gross. >> Well, I don't Okay. What's wrong with, >> dude?
Even though some of them are a little gross
Uh I mean I I'll be honest. I go to HB because one is closer
and two. It's just like Ob's on such a normal one right now.
Obvious on such a [__] normal one. Little groper
really think they got this. They have no idea I'm going to skull
[__] them with my nose right past their computer
screen and straight through their eye socket while making a happy
merchant face like this. He's just like on a totally normal one
right now.
Dude, I don't understand why people pick fights with gropers
ever.
Like it's just like um I don't know. It's just like almost always
a bad idea.
Not that like something bad just they they go so hard for the
internet, man. Just generally like not a good idea. I don't know.
>> I prefer to be >> Maybe maybe he has to be the
guy, okay, who who takes a stand who's like, "No, anti-semitism
is not it not allowed here." Maybe he's the guy. Maybe he'll
stop it. Some don't go to Walmart. But >> okay, so I live
on I live on this side of town where if you walk into like a
Fiesta Mart cuz I have shopped there before cuz they have great
meat prices. You're going to get looks like why the are you in
here, white girl? That's just how it's been. And they >> Do
you ever get those looks at Fiesta >> Um I [clears throat]
have >> Oh, she has. >> But I went in to buy like
fajita mix one time like like the meat and I brought it to my
friend's house and they were like, "Oh, you got grandad." And
I was like, "What do you mean?" I told them we have like seven
people here. And they're like, "That's not for like 20 people."
Like they thought you were done. I was
>> okay. Okay. >> Same with there's a meat market
down the street from my house. Collaborra meat market number
I don't know. And I love to go there cuz I want I they have great
product and I want to support them, but they're like to me so
it's not just me. >> Yeah. But did you call them a slur?
>> No. Absolutely not. And I walk in like kind of like
humbly like
Does Caleb not understand? Okay. If you're if you're like anti-racist,
you should understand something, okay?
white people are the least racist race. Okay? When white people
deal with other Trust me, that's just factually correct. That's
factually obviously true. Least racist race. Okay?
I know people don't like hearing that. I know they don't. But
people are racist to white people sometimes. It's just they don't
really care about it. Like most white people can't understand
it. They just think, "Oh, that person's a dick. They don't It's
They're not really thinking about it, right? >> Bring Fox
with >> this woman. This woman just happens to see racial
animous everywhere, so she's like tuned in." All right. >> I
don't bring Fox with me. You can't [clears throat] You can't
tame him. >> What does he do? >> I am not counting
Eastern Europe or the Balkans. Okay. Not counting Eastern Europe
or the Balkans
or really Russia broadly. All right. Western North American white
people least racist race. All right. Western, you Western European
white people, least racist race. >> That's the mark. >> Nothing.
He's just He's He's not
>> He says he should just be kept inside. He's not meant
for society. That's his words, not mine. >> What does that
mean? I don't know. >> If you have someone who's like an
avid Nick Finas watcher, they they probably Yeah, they probably
should be like kept inside. They're like highlyer
beyond like he's
he's a lot. We have wide We have wide variety of I I let anyone
work here with any political beliefs. I have Aaron on, you know,
the on the left and I think Brandon's a Fentes watcher. >> We
let he's I happen to felt unsafe around him. >> Okay. Well,
there you have. >> That's definitely one of the Latino
>> To be real, I get um I get pissed off at some of the
things Nick says. I think he goes too far with it. >> I've
never seen it, honestly. >> It seems like it's just for
clickbait, >> bro. It's like it's one of those things.
I swear to God, people are like mad at Tucker for normalizing
it. Somehow Nick went from like kind of unknown to like known
by literally everyone in a 8 to 12 month period.
Like it's it's the generational run is not a joke. It's it was
literally a generational run. >> But I mean, you have like,
you know, 20-year-olds that are like basically sucking him off
every single word he >> Nick, if you want to debate and
you watch Financial Audit, uh, feel free. >> He's a He's
a very smart person, honestly. I mean, dude, to have that much
of a political following and when he was like 18 or 17, it's
freaking nuts. Anyways, >> honestly, I can't even speak
on him. I've literally never watched him. >> You should.
Just so you kind of >> uh Full of Hell, I I don't think
anybody was I don't think very many people were like me. I watched
him cuz I was like, "Oh, this guy understands populism. He understands
how to control like populist rhetoric, how to how to message
in a populist way. Like, he understands that better than anybody
on the internet." Probably about as well or even better than
Steve Bannon. That seems really, really scary considering all
the
>> That was why I watched. >> And I know the hype
was when it's part of your internet. Um, >> well, he had
a Tucker Carlson interview that's going viral. I feel like I
want to watch that at least for the sake of >> That's what
I'm saying. >> Right. Cuz it is like lots of rage,
on this Amazon card. >> Yeah. But that was at,000
in May. >> Okay. But now you're not going to bring in any
money. >> Well, now it's just going to be >> So,
what is it going to be? It's going to be Okay, so we make So,
credit card debt is here. It's summertime, so we're going to
start paying it down. Balances and time scale pays it down. Uh
oh, it's winter time now. It starts going up again. We're going
to be in this repeated cycle of never actually been able to pay
them off because we Yeah, but we racked them up when cold. We
pay >> because wasn't always working because Okay. Well,
now he won't be able to. >> Uh, your body, my choice. Hi,
I'm your Republican congressman. There's like a couple of them.
He also just he I'll be real. He seeped into like black culture,
too. What's that family that always reacts to stuff and they
always react to all the Fentes clips? Like the big Fentes clips.
Career family. I think the Care family stuff was big.
Just Instagram reels was massive for him. Now Fox won't be able
to. I mean, he'll get a job, but it's going to be like not great.
His career opportunities for a while at least will not be. He's
going to be dropping the fries. I don't think so. He'll stick,
but we're in a tighter time market right now. >> I know.
But he can always get job in electrical. But that's the thing.
It's likeing up his mental health because he absolutely hates
it. He's shouldered through it for 5 years and like that's part
of why he's having these like mental breakdowns and I don't want
you to think like oh poor you don't want to work. It's like no
like he wants to work. He does work. He's a hard worker. You
can only go so far in a job if it's like it's one thing to be
like it's not my favorite. It's another thing to be like this
is crushing me and I hate this more than anything. Makes me want
to [__] like every day. >> Okay. Uh >> and
that's where he's at with it. But he'll still go back to it.
>> Can you turn on Brandon's mic real quick? Uh, Brandon.
Uh, Brandon, as a Fenta's uh, watcher, is Nick going to be happy
or upset that a >> He's going to be furious about this.
This is
Brandon will know. >> Black man is watching him. He's only
half black. Uh, I don't think he'll care. Oh. >> Oh, sorry.
I didn't realize that was going to be the question. >> No,
Fentes. Fentes. Everybody's a viewer. Okay.
Even black people send super chats. Okay. No, I don't think Okay.
No, he's not a racist, but foxes.
WHAT? WHAT?
I Dude, the world's so cooked and I just see it every day. The
world is so >> Okay, thank you. Very good. He's made friends
with this like white nationalist guy in prison. >> Oh,
but they can't accept him because, you know, he's black. >> Oh,
no.
This this can't be. I'm 1002% African with a 2% margin of error.
>> That dude knows. Whoever watches Nick knows what I'm
saying. [laughter] >> Brandon, we'll talk. Brandon, >> we'll
talk in the post show. We have a lot to talk about in oh my goodness
like [laughter] okay the Amazon card 2000 okay went over the
balance minimum payment $109 13 years to pay this one off if
you don't purchase daily make minimums but you're purchasing
and $80 of interest is acrewing you've had multiple late fees
this year so far almost $1,000 in interest pull up your Amazon
for me and started screen recording if you could
>> boy I think I can justify most of these >> let's
find out are we going to see a white hooded outfit in there we
don't >> bro I don't Oh, >> just so we're clear,
his dad was black and we have we had a great relationship.
His dad is what? He's passed away. So, >> Did he know you
had a great >> Yes. He loved me more than Fox.
Maybe not. Issue. Did you get Wi-Fi? >> I'm on the Wi-Fi.
It's on. This is not me. I know that. Uh there's two different
like $45 charges. Those were [snorts] comforters. >> Why
don't you connect to 5G? I bet you like that. >> I'm on
5G. >> Are you scared? a little bit [laughter] if you want
to go into all of that. Yeah, sure. >> I don't know. I
just assumed
>> I never looking at that kind of stuff. I don't even
know what people >> Well, it's supposedly very bad for
your health and it's like >> what's good for my health
is looking at your Amazon. >> Uh well, the Wi-Fi is on
and I cannot get service in your thing. I'm turning the Wi-Fi
off. There's nothing. Look, I'm not wearing >> uh close
and reopen. >> Okay. So, two of them were purchases for
um comforters for my kids down comforters because I knew the
winter was coming. I don't want to pay that. I don't want to
pay to have the heat on it because we just use like window units
and like space heers and I would be like super expensive to do
that and it would be cheaper to just buy like nice temperatures
for them. So that's one of the purchases. >> You have your
kids down? >> No, they are both um they are not neurode
divergent. They are
>> I work with special needs children and I really enjoy
it. I enjoy that aspect of it. Like if it was just special needs
and it was and I'll still >> you just called them spurs
like
30 minutes ago. >> Continue to do it like I will. It's
just I can't turn it on Wi-Fi cuz I turned it off cuz it wasn't
working. >> Turn it back on. [groaning] So, we can say
all the words, but we throw in a little and all of a sudden too
far. >> Well, I'm not going to say that to them, but there
are some people who are kind. >> I have people who are
smarter than the normal people. Wi-Fi is on and it's in there.
I don't know. >> Yeah, exactly. >> And all of a sudden,
now the moment I use it, it's good and going >> good. Then
you have the magic touch. >> Yeah, cuz I followed the instructions.
>> Monster naturals deodorant. Still on that hippie. >> That
is for my child and it contains no aluminum or chemicals. She
is starting to get stinky. It's natural. >> It's deodorant.
doesn't have phthalates or estrogen disruptors or whatever. >> Right.
And she's stinky. >> She stinks. No, now she's not cuz
she has it. >> Oh, okay. >> We had to get that. >> Uh
metallic free setting powder. >> That was for Halloween
makeup. >> Okay. Lots more makeup stuff. Lots more. >> Black
face paint. >> Oh my goodness. >> We're doing black
face. >> Oh, on Halloween tomorrow. >> They are skeletons.
They They are both >> Costumes. Costumes. Costumes. >> A
likely story. >> Speakers, but those were refunded. Lego
said that was uh back. I never got that. I never got that. That
was for her. She wanted Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh yep. Lots of different
cables, comforters, weekly planner, brackets, floating brackets,
bra extenders. >> I did get a bra extender cuz I'm getting
>> Oh [laughter] well, don't do that. >> Swim more.
Lots of blankets as you said. Lots of sports athleisure. >> That
was T-ball, >> dishwasher stuff.
>> Bif focal reading sunglasses. >> That was for
my mother and she paid me for those. >> How old's your
mom? >> Uh 73. >> And your dad? >> What happens
when they pass away? You'll just live here rent free, pay the
property taxes. >> I'm the only I am the only um benefactor.
So whatever they have will come to me. And I'm actually quite
nervous because I don't want to off everything that they've worked
their entire lives for. >> Well, at this rate, you will
be multivitamins, a watch, reptile bull, uh, heat lamp, and yeah,
if we can't afford to pay the own bills for the kids, I'm like,
we have snake. Oh, four things are in the cart. Let's see. The
mythic of normal by someone
healing toxic culture. >> These are books on like to send
to in jail, but I get them from a cheaper website, but I just
Amazon. >> No, Albert. I think Ali Press. >> Big
Boys and Girls Union suit, thermal >> That was for the
costume. >> AliExpress. Yeah, that was from the costume,
but we ended up not >> Caleb, pull up her AliExpress account.
We need to check her AliExpress purchases right now.
>> She's getting the fetish is [laughter] not so exaggerating.
That's completely >> husband's card. Six to seven. What
is six to seven? 6 to seven cards or
>> Oh. Uh, okay. $1,000 and you have no access to it >> for
his Yeah. So, >> but what's happening while he's in prison
then? >> It's just there and I'm not paying it. >> Okay.
So, it'sing his credit. >> Well, I'm planning on when the
tax return comes I can pay off that flat. It's thousand dollars.
It would be under a year old. And that would get off if you don't
even know how to get in it. >> I think I can from not the
regular desktop or from the laptop. But he has to re give me
the password information. And like I I don't I think it's doable.
I think it's doable.
>> And it's just a thousand. I mean just >> now secret
bank credit. What's going on with this? >> That is only
for dentist and vet. And I assume you don't have insurance for
both of you. >> I have insurance. I do have insurance but
um >> the snake. >> What? No pet insurance.
>> just insurance for humans. Wait. >> Pet insurance
is good. I don't know if I'd get it for a snake. >> Why
not? >> Is that all you have? Well, I don't know if anyway.
Okay, here we go. Um, we have two chickens. My mom mainly takes
care of that and pays for that. We have a snake, a fish, a dog,
and three [laughter] cats. >> Oh, for sake. You have no
penetrance for any of them. >> Um, no. >> Well, I
don't know how you could afford it anyway, but I don't know how
you can afford an emergency if it popped up. >> We can't.
We're We would be using a credit card, which is what I want to
We have. This is not okay. It's not okay. It hasn't been okay
for the past like 5 >> I agree. Yeah. You've done nothing
in the last 5 years. >> No, I disagree with that. I mean,
we got someone arrested and uh I'm paying off these cards. I
I swear you're in like a you're in a moon cycle, though. It's
like, yes, you do get higher income in the summer, so you pay
them down. Not all the way because there these are obviously
not paid off as we're entering this cold season and the cold
season happens you can now live off of 1 1500 with two kids and
someone in prison that you're also trying to support but it wasn't
also all these dogs I know not always and then it goes back up
and then by the time we have the high income I just I think you're
in a moon cycle we used to happily wait for swim lesson season
as we called it to buy our Amazon to buy our Amazon lists this
year we did not do that this year I paid off the debt I paid
off all of as much as I could I was paying like at least half
my income toward the debt to get it gone >> I hope that
works but now your income's dried so I think it's going to can
balloon back up we'll see >> it can't I need it what do
you mean it Is the course careers for real? Because >> of
course Why would I not give that to >> I don't know. Because
I feel like it's just going to I'm going to I'm going to put
all this time and effort into it and then it's not actually going
to like produce a result. >> Oh, you mean the result of
it? So, it adds to your resume and skill set heavily. You have
to remember in general right now it is a tight labor market.
So, that is regardless of what your education is. However, having
an extra tool like a certification to course careers can put
you and you'll be an architectural drafter and it's like >> that
depends on you, your resume, your experience. I don't have Exactly.
And that's where a certification can help. But um it also depends
on your interview skills and how you form your resume. Okay.
Well, it depends on a lot of that, right? So, >> well,
I that's why I'm nervous. It's like, okay, obviously I'm going
to do it. Obviously, I want to do it. I was going to pay for
it out of pocket to do >> You ever leave a job and think
I'll roll over that 401k later because yeah, later comes retirement
to the void. Head I need a break from being chlorinated. I'm
swimming in bleach. That's fine. Listen, you get that for free
instead of spending hundreds of dollars and you know with your
Okay. When you get a job, uh set up a ch >> You have health
insurance for kids even? I don't know, man. >> Account
set up direct deposit and then you immediately get hundreds of
dollars for free. >> Oh, okay. Yeah. So there you go. So
instead of paying for the certification, do that. Okay. Special
link in the >> I'm like
I'm very I was very into this. I need a bit of a palic cleanser
I think before we finish. I'm going to I'm going to at the end
of the section and then I think I'm going to pull up some >> that
are that will provide at least through November, December, January.
Like I'm I'm I'm confident that I will have things there. Like
I have another cleaning position at the pool. I mean >> cleaning
at the pool. I will clean I will do what I have to do. And just
saying I can do swim lessons. Like I have I have probably three
special needs clients that would take uh twice a week. I have
um probably two or three littles that would take a few times
a week and I have I have two adults and I have a one person who
um wants adaptive swimming. He has a spinal cord injury and so
I have that. So I have people that I can do the lessons and like
you know I will but I'm like dude I'm so out on this. >> Yeah.
I mean I'm being told you've been asking clients swim lessons
if you if they if you could clean their house. >> Yeah.
I appreciate the hustle because you have to. The care credits
at 92265 >> that gets paid off every year on a regular
basis. That is the one that I hope so with a $41 minimum to payment.
But uh you're solid with it. And that's why there was a late
fee this month >> for Care Credit. >> Cuz I'm solid
with it. Yes. A late fee this month. And not only that, but approximately
a late fee. I'm going to say 6 months this year.
>> I don't know. >> Five to six months this year.
>> Don't know. >> Okay. This is the one that you're
so confident in. >> It's because every year I pay it down
to zero. With swim lesson money. The first >> every year,
Listen, here's the thing. Every year can quickly turn into we
can't this year.
>> Just because it's happened doesn't mean it's going to
happen. >> I know. But I'm like, it's like, okay, I'm fully
confident that by next summer, we could be completely out of
debt and like clear possibly have a little bit of an emergency
fund started, but from there, where is it going to go? Because
it's like, oh, you need to get retirement. You need It seems
completely overwhelming to me, especially like even attempting
to buy a house. It's like at this point in time, >> why
would you? Why was that even a >> Because in the next because
in the next 5 years, you know, my daughter will be uh 13,
>> twobedroom. She can't share a room with her brother.
And so it's like, do I build onto the house that I >> But
you can still rent there. Definitely don't build onto the house.
But then if I'm renting, it's going to be at least 2,000 to get
a three-bedroom like apartment or duplex or whatever. At that
point, wouldn't I just rather have a mortgage payment? >> It
depends. Depends where everything's looking. At this point, it's
still renting makes more sense. >> At this point, I feel
like I'm going to be 60 and that's >> Yes, you are on schedule
for that. So, that's what we need to fix. The deferred interest
will hit and some in a couple months and a couple months more
for the other ones. So, that that's pretty >> If I can
get to February without putting anything on credit cards, then
the tax return will hit. >> I've already seen you do that
on these
>> Gap card, including $634 of purchases on this gap card.
>> That's correct. That is for clothing for >> I
know what it is. That's kind of what cap is. But that is still
going against what you said you need to not do. >> No,
they needed to have clothes for the >> Well, you still
did the thing you said you need to not do regardless. Like you
can justify anything, but to execute the plan you want to do,
you have to >> It's a $30 minimum payment. They have to
have clothes. They do. I'm not saying they don't, but you do.
You specifically said as long as I don't put cards on pay, you
know. >> Yes, you're correct. And then you immediately
do. So on multiple cards we looked at so far. This takes two
years to pay off. By the way, >> that'll be paid off by
next. >> Okay. Well, well, well. And then it doesn't. And
then we are where we are today. Look, look what you have done
until always paid off. >> And then they're always brought
back off. So that means nothing. >> But what's the problem
with that? It's only [laughter] interest and fees on Care Credit.
So >> But then what is the like good credit you're always
talking about? Like if it's good credit is paying off every single
month. >> I do pay the minimum payment every >> LATE
FEE THIS MONTH. >> I'VE DUDE I'VE HAD FOR LIKE 10 years.
>> Doesn't matter. You're not a credit card person. You've
had two late fees this year so far on this one. Two on another
card. Six on the last one. Hundreds of dollars of interest to
zero this year. It's been paid to zero. >> It doesn't matter
if it goes back up then and then has late fees and interest acro.
It doesn't matter. >> What's the point of it? >> What
are you talking about? To pay it off every month and if you can't
don't have it. It's not a tool to your advantage. No one can
pay off like $600 a month. >> I do. They do. He does. He
does. He >> Work for y'all. You need some organizing done
up there, by the way. I Yes, I can I can have this place looking
like 10 >> We've given up on this place because we want
to move somewhere >> and I'll be your mover. >> Okay.
Yeah, I'll Well, >> I'm serious. I'm great at moving. I
moved like 13 times in a few years.
>> Maybe. I don't know. >> That is the weirdest flex
I've ever heard of in my entire life. >> Well, either way,
>> I'm just saying the the problem is I need I need solid
work because >> this is also the spending problem. when
and I got married. When Fox and I got married, it was supposed
to be that, you know, he was going to be the the bread winner
and I was going to be the stay at home mom and we did that for
a while until it's like >> You wanted to be full tread.
>> We did want to be full tread. >> Okay. But he
couldn't even go outside >> and then I would Well, he forced
himself to um he's quite socialized. It's just like this weird
little mask he puts on. I think I don't know. He's really fun.
>> The 50% black guy. Like is that what you're saying?
I don't >> No, he's just fun to um You would think he's
a really social gray person, but he like actually has social
anxiety and just stuff. But um anyway, so yeah, we were supposed
to be full trad and then it was like I started working part-time
and I always kept the summer job cuz it was just so much income.
And then slowly but surely now it's like okay now it's >> I
don't
have to have that money. >> I can't I can't do it. >> And
so I'd rather like kind of slowly back down those hours and get
something that can be year round for me that is um just sustainable.
I mean I could appreciate that but there's also just lots of
issues in here that are not an income thing cuz here's the thing.
the Lowe's. I'm not going to put it down as a debt because it
only has 16 bucks on it. Really? Pay it off. There you go. But
this is indicative of the problem because you had almost $700
on you. You paid it off, but yet fee and interest still accured,
meaning you did not manage it correctly. You're not a credit
person. It was a late fee. You've had about four late fees this
year so far on this card and hundreds in interest. You do not
pay this off. It is a 37% interest. And >> he wasn't. >> What?
Him? Is this his card? >> It's not on your credit. You're
an authorized user. >> I don't know. I don't know. >> I
can't
like people. Dude, I I like manage my finances reasonably well.
I don't pay late fees. I sometimes pay late fees on bills because
I don't have like two of my bills autoscheduled, but it's like
$20 twice a year or something. And listening to people mismanage
their finances gives me like immense financial anxiety somehow.
Like super bad financial. It's like I actually get super anxious
listening to somebody talk about this. I'm going to watch Nick
White do something cool. Give me a >> Easy. There's a little
bit of resistance when I'm pulling the side panel down. Like
it's like taped at the bottom maybe. Do I just pull the side
panel off >> Yeah. Yank it off. The tape feels just plastic
locking it in. >> Oh my gosh. [laughter]
>> there's a little bit of resistance. >> That just
made me feel so much better. Oh my god. >> Like it's like
taped at the bottom. Maybe. Do I just pull the side panel off
>> One more time.
>> Yeah. Yank it off. The tape feels just plastic LOCKING
IT IN. OH MY GOD. >> UH that granite countertop or something.
No, he didn't hit the the glass on the bottom. I don't think
that's the I don't think that's glass. I think it's just like
putting that kind of pressure that kind of like corner pressure
on it. Sheer force and it just like
just spider through the whole thing. I mean, he did hit the counter.
Yes. But I'm saying I don't think Do you think these edges are
glass? Maybe they are. It looks like this might be glass all
the way to the top and black on the bottom. Oh, maybe it is glass
the whole way through,
It is glass the whole way through now that I'm looking at it.
You can see the kind of cracks here. Oh yo yo yo. Oh
>> Oh boy. Who is he listening to? AI on his phone. Nick
White asks AI for PC build tips. AI's genius advice. Just yank
the side panel off. Dam. Um.
>> Act for a little bit. >> Actually, I don't. >> Okay.
We're transparent. I mean I >> We're transparent. >> Me
and him together. Yes. It's not like he bought anything in secret.
Like I knew he was using that and I was like, "Why are we doing
this?" He's like, "I need it for my work cuz he lost all his
tools." Blah blah blah drama. Um and he's like, "I'll pay it
off." And then he like couldn't. >> What even is that?
What did you send me? What is this drama? >> This is Venmo
exported as an Excel >> That's what they sent me. Not some
noob.
>> medical. Well, there's lots of denes and Well, okay.
So, what am I looking at here specifically? Cuz >> that's
just all medical stuff that was like partly paid off, but we're
like >> for Fox or you? >> Yes, Fox. >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. You owe $14,000.
>> Medical. Well, that will go on collections now. I mean,
I I can't what am I going to do about that? I can't even get
groceries. >> You can get on a minimum payment and they
can make it income based and yours is very low. So, it would
be super small, but at least so they don't send it to collections
of credit, especially if you're talking about getting having
to get another apartment to get another house. You don't want
credit and we already know Fox is going to have credit cuz the
Fox card is going to be gone. >> It'll be paid off. It'll
be fine. >> How you have access to it? >> I'll figure
it out. >> So, what the cost so much money? >> He
got severely sick and he couldn't work for like 3 months and
he they ran all this test in the emergency room and it was like
it was really up. So, cuz we didn't have insurance at the time.
Now, we do have insurance. Um so yeah and then that was also
from recently when he was in the jail and then got staff which
turned into MRSA and then he had to have the um the emergency
surgery. It was from that too. >> Okay on here ally. I
see a payment. >> So many excuses >> dude. But I
don't see
the balance. I'm assuming this is a car. Oh here it is the car.
>> Oh Kia 2016 Kia. >> Yeah it's like what >> is
this your primary driver? Yes. >> Yeah. $5,82425.
What is the interest on this? >> A lot. >> What?
What is it? >> I don't Was it [laughter] >> payment
is pretty small at 17702. >> I assume the interest is like
at 25%. >> When did you get this and why? >> Oh,
this is a story. Um, okay. So, uh, Fox had a truck that my parents
actually bought him and then I had a car that my parents actually
bought me and then, um, he crashed his truck and then >> Should
it be should it be a story?
>> I got in an accident with my car and my car was fixable
but >> Okay. Also, quick question. Has Hutch been watching
the GOP Civil War stuff at all? I'd love to see some Hutch opinions
on this [__]
>> His wasn't. And then my stepdad was like, "No, this
car isn't safe. You just need to take my other extra car." So
then I was driving his extra car and then we just had the one
car that we were sharing for like 9 months because we couldn't
afford another car. And then finally we were like, "Dude, we
have to get another car. So we're going to buy a car." This is
the first car we ever bought either of us. Oh, I think Fox bought
one other car. We went there and we thought it was fine and I
read the contract and I was like, "Yeah, this will be fine."
And we got it. It turned out to be a lemon. And we had tried
to get it fixed through them through the through the warranty
and it went into a >> How much do you think it's worth?
>> $5,000. Okay. >> You're about break even. >> Oh,
no. We're We're not even close to breaking even. We're in the
whole >> pay for all that. >> We paid for that out
of pocket. We paid the down payment. Oh, wait a minute. I think
I paid half the down payment and my mom paid half of it. And
then um there's no personal responsibility here, >> dude.
It's embarrassing. >> Is 45 and student loans yours?
>> I'm on a repayment plan with that, which is like pay
as you earn. I've been on it since 2013 and because u my income
is so low next year payment as earned I don't know but everything's
gotten a lot more >> that's fine with whatever they decide
I'm not going to complain >> well you'll be income based
on the repayment assistance program if that program that you're
on right now is no longer valid I don't know zero for 10 >> well
now it'll probably be like a couple percentage points >> which
is fine I mean >> that starts next summer >> that's
another thing that I'm going to be different it's like most people
like oh student loans it's like well I signed the paper I I can't
believe I haven't >> out went back like a thousand times
>> yes and still don't have the paper to show for it >> well
you shouldn't need to at 40 at this point you should have the
work experience that speaks for itself without the degree >> that's
what I'm saying and If I would have stayed in >> I I don't
I don't I don't know. I just I I need a >> I do. It's like
No, you don't. You literally are like a swim instructor. That's
not work experience. You have like I've heard stripper, swim
instructor, and possibly Oh, bakery were like the three jobs
I've heard. What the is she talking about? >> Direction
to be like pointed in because I obviously have like skills that
are usable, especially I think working with like special needs
kids for like so long. I obviously have like patience, determination,
uh different qualities that would be great for any employer.
I'm not too particular about what it would be. I'd love to watch
your resume show because it it also depends how you're framing
it. If it looks like you're gonna just accept a job, do accept
a job for a quick page and immediately leave. No, >> cuz
lots of rums look like that. >> At the top of it, I'll
review it. Okay. At the top of it, I put that I am uh eager to
benefit a company to help make them money. I want to be a money
maker for the company to benefit the company. >> Does Fox
have student loans? >> Okay. Surprisingly, no overdress
in the check account. I want to make sure first though before
I go in. Oh, nope. Yeah. No. 130 overdraft fees is here. Great.
Great. I want to make sure first. Is that all the debt we got?
>> Overdrafting. Why the >> Cuz your income hasn't
gone down until >> No, I mean the income didn't I don't
start swim lessons until May. Now I had a tiny bit of income
coming in from like part-time coaching, but that was just like
a few hundred maybe like up to 600 a month to like pay off some
of the credit card minimum pay payments. And then like Fox was
like working and paying most of the bills, but and some of that
he he wasn't cuz >> she teaches kids to swim and she's
a lifeguard. She teaches special needs kids to swim too >> of
because of mental health cuz he's going to prison because he
broke his own morality and now his wife and kids are going to
be abandoned for a year.
An interesting one. Amazon restaurant.
>> I get 50% off and I spend time. Yeah. 30 bucks there.
>> I looked at it after I sent it to you and I was like,
"Oh, I'm >> Yeah. So, Amazon pool food. Amazon pool food.
Amazon pool food." Prime Video. Amazon. Amazon. >> The
Prime Video was for my friend and they paid me for that. >> Okay.
Well, there was two of them. And then Amazon and then Pool Food.
Amazon Evergreen Restaurant. Oh, more. Okay, good. Netflix. Brevity.
Amazon. Swimlet. Swimlet. Brand videos. Texas.
>> Swim away. >> Wait. GM. Yeah. Texas GM. American.
Etsy. Costco is probably groceries.
>> That's not good. Etsy. Not good. >> Oh. Can vend
machine. Vending machine. Vending machine. Vending machine. Vending
machine. Vending machine. Vending machine. >> That is from
when I went to the prison to visit. >> How many vending
machines you need to do out there? Well, I have the kids, so
I have the kids. And I'm like, we're there for 4 hours and they
have nothing in your house. How are you going to prison? You're
not allowed to bring What do the kids think of this? >> They
know that if you uh break the law, you go to jail. >> Yeah.
What do they think about it? >> They are sad, but they
know that uh >> Do people know daddy's in jail? >> Uh
I've told them I'm >> Jeez, Caleb's getting a little sharp
here. What the [__] >> Like, you can tell you
want, but you need to know that if you that you need to know
that if you make the choice to tell people, you might get made
fun of because this is something weird that like most families
don't have to go through. So, they kind of keep it to >> Yeah.
Very smart. Amazon Uh something department not allowed to bring
food and >> education and Amazon. Um yeah, which makes
sense. He already got in trouble for smuggling once already.
No more
>> Apparently they get um >> some of the inmates
in some of the inmates get quote unquote packages from
>> Well, yes. Prisons have a massive smuggling problem.
Of course they get >> I never knew it was like from drones.
That's crazy. >> Makes sense. Modern day technology.
>> that makes sense. >> No, he's not involved in
any of that. >> What I don't see is any savings or >> Yeah.
Is that correct?
>> I am I am lined up to
>> probably inherit the group swimming lesson program.
My boss doesn't have any children or really any family >> cuz
I've been there for 15 years and I care about it more than anyone
because I'm responsible. >> Why would she pick you? >> Well,
she did obviously because she trusts me. She gave me a notorized
copy of her will. >> Whoa. And what will Okay. So, what
is this valued at? >> I'm I'm not sure, but potentially
40 to 60,000 um in two months. >> Okay. Okay. Well, let's
see how you manage it cuz we have how you manage it. >> I've
already I've already managed my own swim lesson program at the
Nitorium in the way that she does it. So, it's viable and I can
definitely maintain it. The only reason I can't do it full-time
at the Nitorium is because I don't have the teacher supply. During
the summer, she has the supply of teachers cuz everyone's off
of school. But during the school year, it's way harder to get
someone who's just going to work 2 or 3 hours and that's it.
>> Listen, I'm going to make a budget, but before we do,
I mean, we got this this episode was just wild and we have so
many more wild things in the post show. More of her backstory,
you can only imagine that got her into this. looking at her resume
and just even uh her mom's just endlessly bailing out and we're
going to talk about >> Let's not talk to Please. I don't
want to I don't want to just over her. >> Who? My mom.
>> You don't have to. >> Okay, so totally
>> Caleb's going to blow her mom up for for taking care
of her. That's [__] up, >> Income? Uh 1,500,
I guess. Rent, we're going to say zero because I'm required to
utilities. Do you pay that? >> I pay the electric and she
pays the >> How much is electric? >> Electric is
about 250 a month. >> Internet 80. Do you >> I pay
it. >> Let's get your minimum debt payments without student
loans or medical yet.
Okay. Well, let's see the third already.
Two cents. Now, to be clear, I want to make it very clear cuz
obviously this is going to be very tight. >> Do not pay
debt if it comes between choosing to pay a minimum payment or
paying for utilities and food on the table. Debt can go itself
when it comes to the necessities of the house. To be very clear,
I want you to pay debt. I want you to pay for Okay. Phone bill.
My mom pays it. Groceries. What do you budget for? Groceries.
Um, so we do Costco like maybe every 2 months maybe. >> her
parents must have like a lot of money, right? Like realistically
her parents are older.
She must have so much wealth coming in from her parents passing.
Like if her parents were to pass away,
right? If she's their only kid and she said that she was their
only kid,
like she's got to have what? At least one other home. At least
one other home. at least like they've got to have some some actual
major savings. >> 6 weeks to 2 months and it's usually
um $200 to $300
and then HB is like anywhere from 50 to 100 a week depending
on how much Costco like kind of the weight the weight is in Costco
cuz I get like a lot of frozen meats and like yogurts and bowls.
>> Tell me for all three of you do 400 a >> 4 to
600. >> Okay. I was going to say >> it depends. So
well >> at minimum given that's I want to say >> They
eat with uh they eat dinner with my mom sometimes cuz like she
picks them up for school. Okay. Vroom from drive drive >> 40
bucks a week. >> Okay. So 160. >> Car insurance.
165. And that's also renters renters's insurance, but I've already
paid that out through I think February. So I don't >> I'll
put an asteris then. Okay. And TV fund. Anything else for you
and the kids? I'm going to say 150. We're keeping it really tight.
Sports activities, whatever. Whatever. Tampons, all the good
stuff. Okay. Medical health. Are there co-pays on a monthly basis
I need to put in? >> Uh no. I mean we have insurance. >> It's
horrible to say, but I can't put any pet insurance. How much
for pet food? Um
60 a month. >> Okay. Subscriptions. I'm not even going
to try. >> I have Netflix and Amazon Prime and >> Let
me see if I can put in 20 and you figure out where it goes. >> 25.
Um is there a gym? >> Okay. Absolutely not. >> I
just Okay, >> bro. I can't even pay to like get groceries.
I'm not going to the gym every subscription. >> You do
push-ups at your house for free. >> Yeah, sure. That's
[laughter] fine. I mean, cuz Yeah, you're already over budget
by hundreds. And I didn't even do pen insurance, which you pretty
much have to do at 50 bucks a pop. You're already at 1,900. This
just doesn't make >> I know, but >> which is why
in >> Okay, Caleb, we knew she's going to be significantly
underwater from the beginning of this. Why is he like, "Oh man,
now that I add up the numbers, this seems like you're not really
in a sustainable path at all." No, you knew the whole time. >> In
my mind, debt will go up and then you focus on paying it off
again in the summer. Then it goes, it's going to be a >> I
need a solid career. That's I need to be the bread winner. I
need to be the bread winner and when Fox gets out, he can figure
out what he's going to do. We have two full-time incomes would
be >> I agree with that. Listen, I'll get you as many course
certifications as you Usually we just do one, but you need to
figure this out for this. I'm doing this for the kids. I'm not
even doing it for you, honestly. For the kids, cuz you need to
go get a [__] career now. So, you're going to g gather
as much as you can. You're going to start working, but it's going
to be harder to start a career 41. It really is. You can't not
that it can't be done, but um from scratch without the experience.
Yes, it will be harder. So, you're going to focus on that and
then you're going to go hard into grinding 40 hours a week at
a job that is a consistent level income while working second
and third jobs as well. Now, once you actually start bringing
in like 2500 bucks, we should be able to tackle down this uh
a lot of this debt relatively decently. It's going to take a
few years still. >> But remember, in June, I'm going to
be >> We're not relying on that anymore, though, cuz you're
focusing on getting a career now that it's consistent, >> right?
But I'm But I can't leave the pool. I have to at least maintain
some That's another That's another part of it. Complication.
If I'm going to inherit the program, I have to at least Okay.
When's the inheritance going to >> Well, she's like 75,
I think. >> So, I don't know how long she's going to be
doing it. >> So, well, you haven't had a >> I mean,
a little bit. She'll probably do it for another 10 years. >> How
do you start a career if in the summer you can't do career? >> I
don't know. Okay, then I'm just going to go because I would work
both. Because I would work both. I would work two jobs like you're
suggesting or three jobs. >> Yeah, but the hours are okay,
whatever. Hammer financial score. Okay. Spending a budget, you
overspend 0 out of 10. Debt. Uh, well, medical is basically in
collections, but it's not technically yet. 1 out of 10 for your
income level for sure. Emergency funds 0 out 10. Retirement 0.
Real estate 0 out of 10. You don't own the house yet. You're
not on the deed yet. Round it up.5 out of 10. Click that join
button for an extra insane 20 minutes of this episode and every
other episode by joining Amber Lee, including three. God damn.
Okay. Well, that's the episode. She must have been a ma massive
up in her early 20s and 30s. She actually has zero skills besides
swim instruction, time limited, and special needs care. Not qualified.
She also hasn't gotten a degree.
Crazy dude. One took, you need to stop being obsessed with whatever
this medication is, okay? It's you need to you need to chill.
All right? You need to chill. Gentle whale, I don't even know
who's on these teams anymore. Okay.
Probably Falcons, though. Probably
Okay, what do we got? We got what? 30 45 minutes left. 30 minutes
left. All right. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I got a bit of a hutch a little
bit of a hutch tent piece right here at the end. Why not?
Why not? Why not? Why not?
Check it out.
Wee bit of hutch tent. We're going to go back to Ben Shapiro.
We're going to pivot away from Dems being super in array to Republicans
in a complete state of in a disarray. I'm I don't know about
you guys, but I am pretty fascinated by what is happening right
now. I'm just fascinated with the idea that Nick Fuentes, literally
just one guy,
>> has been so disruptive
to Republican party politics over the last like month, you know,
longer than that, but it's really reached like a fever pitch
in the last month. >> Hey folks, I want to do something
different on today's show. But we're going to cover one topic.
>> And this video uh on Twitter has 52,000
13,000 retweets,
and 27,000
replies. That usually means
it is a show
down here in the in the replies. Top replies from Candace Owens.
I feel on an editorial point I was completely unnecessary to
include me in this anti-Tucker rant.
Alas, I shall have to
Well, Candace, I think it's because you have become like a Dave
Chappelle
like an actual black. I think that's why that is. Um,
does she It doesn't seem like she subscribes to any kind of racism
except anti-semitism. I'm not sure that I agree on that one.
>> In depth, [music] that topic is, I think, the most important
thing happening in the >> She's like Alex Jones. Calling
her like a is just weird. It's She's like Alex Jones. She's She's
black Alex Jones. She's Alex Jones with a YouTube account. >> Contro.
I'm very curious if over the course of this term if running on
abolishing ICE actually becomes decently popular. Uh maybe I
I don't know. May maybe I I think like what seems more likely
is a policy of just like having DHS just absorb ICE and just
have you know I I maybe I don't know there's a lot of anger about
ICE. So like maybe I really don't know. >> Was a hot topic
last week but I wanted to take some time to really gather my
thoughts and speak on it in coherent fashion holistic fashion.
That topic is the fragmentation of the political right. That
fragmentation is being caused purposefully by a splinter faction
of people led by a young man named Nick Fuentes. They call themselves
the Gropers. They are white supremacists. They hate women, Hindus,
many types of Christians, brown people of a wide variety of backgrounds.
It's also, I think, important to point out how significant the
Charlie Kirk shooting was for Nick Fuentes cuz Nick Fuentes responded
to that event. >> Bro, why is he he's doing this like days
after it started >> in an extremely savvy way. I think
that was calculated. I think it was deliberate because after
Charlie Kirk died or was killed.
Nick Fuentes immediately
pounced on that
and his I I'm like I'm almost hopeful, but I'm I'm also positive
that there's no way he has a like good a good read on this. It
shouldn't be that hard, but it's almost it feels impossible that
he'd have good read on this, but he's like so close to saying
it. rhetoric was
very lionizing of Charlie Kirk and they, you know, there was
a deep animosity between those two people when Charlie Kirk was
alive.
But what Fuentes did was
exploit that kind of martyr status
and then express, you know, deep respect for a worthy opponent
D. And he was able to tap into, I think, a lot of Kirk's followers
like anger and rage. I'll be real. I don't know if the Kirk response
is super consequential. I think he could have maybe hurt himself
with a bad Kirk response. He was blowing up before the Kirk incident,
right? People are really underelling because they just don't
pay attention. They're really underelling how much this guy was
growing earlier this year, right? Like in literally January,
February, March, April, May. They're like totally undercutting,
undervaluing that, underestimating that and thinking like, oh,
it's like since the Charlie Kirk thing or oh, since the Tucker
Carlson interview, it's the wrong way to look at it. And I think
that had massive appeal.
I I don't know what the numbers are. I have no idea. I don't
really pay attention to those kinds of things. Um, but if I had
to guess, I would say that Fuentes was able to successfully poach
a significant chunk of Charlie Kirk's online base of support.
I think he played that so well for himself. Yeah, I don't I don't
think so. I really I mean, not if they believed in anything Charlie
Kirk believed in. If they were just mindless drones, maybe, which,
you know,
Um, and that has caused this like Nick Fuentes problem to balloon
and get worse. It's just gotten so much worse since Kirk was
shot.
>> Played a huge part, too. >> Again, it's really
really really not gotten like so much worse since the Kirk >> It
really hasn't. >> Uh, Candace is more She's more like >> Candace
played a bigger Candace o the Candace Owens interview would have
played a big role. Um, fighting with him on Twitter would have
played a big role. Mostly it was just him not being deplatformed
and him being like funny and a better speaker than most people,
While saying super transgressive things. It's like a stand-up
comedian who's got a nightly talk show who is saying like politically
relevant stuff. He's very very like it's not talent. It's like
hard work over a period of time. Putting a lot of work into reading
about politics, putting a lot of work into being funny and entertaining
and charismatic, right? All this work over years and years and
years without breaking down
leads to okay now that this guy suddenly popped onto the scene
when things are super politically
and he has got the expertise of like a 10-year veteran in broadcasting
and people just he he popped out of nowhere. Suddenly there's
some guy on the right who's like edgy and funny. He was he just
happened to pop into the market at the perfect time with Trump
up everything, right? Like um I [clears throat] don't know. Cand
Candace is more just like a crazy person. I like I don't think
Candace is very ideological in the same way that uh
Fentes is.
I don't think she's motivated by ideology. I think she's motivated
by something else entirely. Psychosis or
uh narcissism or whatever.
You literally just called her a black N. I didn't mean like she's
maybe I should be more precise, but like the language that she
she's just gone like full zog
like
conspiracy theories, but I don't think she's like motivated by
a belief
I think she I think she is motivated by something else
foreign policy and America's constitution. They admire Hitler
and Stalin and that splinter faction is now being facilitated
and normalized within the mainstream Republican party. The main
agent in that normalization is Tucker Carlson who is an intellectual
coward, a dishonest interlocutor and a terrible friend. And Tucker
Carlson last week was aided, abetted, celebrated for normalizing
within the Republican party by the mainstay organization of the
traditional right, the Heritage Foundation. Now, before we explain
what's been happening, let's make one thing clear. This is not
about free speech or cancellation. It was never about free speech
or cancellation. Free speech has a definition. The right to speak
free of governmental coercion. I believe in it, of course. I've
always defended it. Criticism of bad speech is in fact just a
form of free speech. Cancellation also has a definition. The
banning of particular people, including people like Nick Fuentes,
from platforms like X or Facebook. I believe that Nick Fuentes
is odious and despicable, but I've never called for his cancellation.
And in fact, I've called for his restoration to those services
despite the fact that I think he's odious and despicable.
What makes Nick different from than Ben in their politics? Cuz
I see Spider-Man meme in my head. Um, they have very different
politics. First of all, Nick is uh like a like a literal >> Cool.
What belief does Ben Shapiro support at the Daily Wire that Nick
doesn't express
that um sorry what what belief does Ben disallow the Daily Wire
that Nick expresses other than
beliefs? It's just it seems to me to be just that. There's basically
nothing else. Matt Walsh does hint at white
Matt Walsh uh Matt Walsh will do almost everything Fentes will
do. Now, actually saying the slurs, sure, maybe there's that,
too, but that's probably more just a YouTube monetization thing
than anything else.
>> Uh, anti-semitism
is something that is like a is like axiomatic for him.
Like a lot of Nick's
beliefs and messaging and
comes from
like a deeply rooted
virulent anti-semitism. Uh Nick, I don't think believes in liberal
democracy. I in fact I know he doesn't believe in liberal democracy.
What
What is the anti-semitic
reason for disliking liberal democracy? If he's motivated by
liberal dem like by anti-semitism like the deepest rooted anti-semitism,
what part of not believing in liberal democracy is the anti-semitism
fuel? Where is that I where's the connection? So he's he praises
groups like the Taliban
because they keep women in line. You >> I this sounds like
Nick rhetoric. I just don't know the clip. Did Nick did Nick
say W Taliban at some point? >> And uh >> I might
just not know that one. Uh, you >> I that's not me saying
Nick would never. Okay, I'm obviously not that naive. I'm just
saying I haven't seen that one. That's all. >> Ban fornication
and ban like drug use.
um he's he's uh >> Oh, was this like
was this like oh the Taliban you say the Taliban's bad, but they
uphold some conservative
like conservative ideals or something? >> He wants like
a Christian theocratic dictatorship essentially.
And Ben uh as conservative as Ben is
not it's not he's not committed hard enough for it to be the
Islamic talking points. We'll see. >> Believes in liberal
democracy
which why? He literally constantly sweeps for Trump and says
Trump's nowhere near as bad as you think. Wait,
Hutch, in Hutch's opinion, is it okay to call Charlie Kirk a
fascist? If it's okay to call Charlie Kirk a fascist, then you
absolutely can call Ben Shapiro a fascist. Ben Shapiro enables
all of the same things Charlie Kirk does, and he's done it for
longer in a more effective way than Charlie Kirk has. Charlie
Kirk's operation is better and and more important now, but 6
years ago, the Daily Wire was incredibly important. I understand
there's a lot of contradictions there because how could you support
Donald Trump if you actually believe that? But in Ben's mind,
the left represents a greater threat to liberal democracy than
Trump does.
Totally hallucinate. Like completely hallucinating. This is Trump
really didn't Trump really thought the election was stolen from
him. So like he's not actually breaking the Constitution or doing
something illegal. He thought he was upholding his vow to the
Constitution by looking into the election. It's like, okay, if
you have a totally totally hallucinated belief, you have to you
have to find some evidence for it or shut the [__]
up. >> He believes in the veneer of liberal democracy.
I don't know, guys. Like in terms of
uh pundits, >> no, he doesn't. He has enabled everything
that the Republicans have done. He has been there waiting on
Trump's maintaining Trump's legacy, maintaining Trump's like
wishes just he's been there the whole time sweeping. Okay. He's
like the number one Oh, what is it? Oh, I forget the different
positions in curling. He's not the skip. The skip throws the
the rocks first. But he's he's like a sweeper. Okay, that's what
he is. He's been setting up every every rock the Trump administration
throws. He's there every step of the way. You don't get to say
You don't get to say that any Republican
Why is Hutch even trying to steal Man Ben here? Because Hutch
uh Okay, this is where I'm getting into more of the um Islamic
stuff. Hutch wants to point out how dangerous Nick Fuentes is
because of the anti-semitism. And he wants to make Nick like
a bigger demon than he he wants to make Ben Shapiro. Ben Shapiro's
news network just does Nick Fentes talking points. It has for
five, six years, right? just watered down without the anti-semitism.
Hutch is stupid. Well, Hutch is uninformed.
>> Ben Shapiro is honestly pretty moderate. And this is
the this is the bait and switch that everybody does with Ben
Shapiro. Well, Ben Shapiro like Ben Shapiro doesn't actually
state these beliefs. He monetizes them. He is the person who
monetizes them. All things
compared with like relative to where the movement is at. Uh Ben,
>> the Daily Wire basically tried to build up like Amazon
Prime for the right wing off of the clout capital they had right
in the in the conservative party in the right-wing movement in
like the uh Republican movement. Like they are the people who
made the the trans stuff. That's all Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro.
Jeremy Boring is definitely closer to the center.
Which isn't to say that I find his politics to be centrist. That's
not what I mean. But I mean, relative to
the rest of the right-wing movement, I of course think his politics
are quite extreme. Um, Zack Rip, thank you so much for two months.
Appreciate it. >> It is not cancel. >> Uh, Showdan
Shootman at Hutch, he explicitly said to Destiny, "He acknowledges
Trump's illiberalism, but is a means to an end. This is why we
don't feel bad for Ben Shapiro. This is why we don't feel bad
for him at all."
to draw moral lines between viewpoints. >> Crack Fox, did
I get you for the primer? Thank you, buddy. >> In fact,
we used to call that one of the key aspects of conservatism.
It is not cancellation to refuse to signal boost supporters like
Nick Fuentes. It is not cancellation to criticize Tucker Carlson
for rhetorically fluffing Nick Fentes and other anti-American
crackpots. It's not cancellation if you urge others to stop promoting
those who rhetorically fluff, not apologists. [music] nose. So,
this is how you know, by the way, as we know learned from the
Megan Fox interview. Sorry, Megan Kelly interview, not Megan
Fox. Normal thumbs, not weird thumbs. Okay, we as we learned
there, this is why you know Ben means glazing when he says glossing.
Okay, cuz he's talking about fluffing somebody. Talk about sucking
them off. >> Are all elements of free speech and anyone
who says differently is lying to you and lying for the most cynical
reasons to misdirect from their own >> He's audience captured.
He'd be a never Trumper if he didn't watch all the never Trumpers
get cancelled. Ironically,
no. Wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong. He literally was a never
Trumper. He literally led the never Trump movement.
And then when he realized that he could make a ton of money grifting
the same way Trump did, he cashed the inf of those apologists
and their promoters. The issue here isn't that Tucker Carlson
had this show last week. He has every right to do that. Of course,
the issue here is that Tucker Carlson decided to normalize and
fluff Nick Fuentes and
>> now Ben is kind of using language that the left was
using
in 2017. I don't I' I'd have to go back and look at what Ben
was saying back in 2017, but back then there was a lot of
at least in a in a mechanistic way like in terms of what he's
doing. He is no different than Ben Shapiro in 2015, 2016. Okay.
Ben Tucker sees the winds blowing a different way, realizes he
can't fight the cultural tide right now, and is is cashing in.
Ben Shapiro is going to stand here like a bunch of his fellow
conservatives did and get totally run over
and maybe he'll he'll stand on this hill and die on this hill,
but it is the same hill. It is like an adjacent hill to the one
that he ran from before, the never Trump hill. Okay, the Trump
movement is not significantly different than the the the original
manga movement from 2016. Not significantly different than the
Groper movement. One major difference, which is why Ben won't
won't, you know, opt in this time. But it's not that's just a
difference in group. Okay, the Gropers happen to dislike about
as much as the original manga people hated illegal immigrants.
Okay, hated Latinos.
The left saying like, don't normalize Trump. Don't normalize
Milo Milo Yiannopoulos and Gavin McKinnis and uh Stefan Malyu
and um
you know don't platform because then it normalizes them. We shouldn't
we shouldn't let people get used to Trump being normal.
if I had to sus, if I had to guess, I would say Ben back then
was saying
that uh he was taking the free speech absolutist position, which
is that um I don't know, maybe that doesn't directly contradict
what he's saying here because >> Ben was absolutely not
a free speech absolutist for anti-semites, the alt-right. Absolutely
not. >> Because he's not saying that you shouldn't platform
Nick Fuentes. He's saying that the problem was that Tucker invited
him on and then essentially agreed with him about his uh takes.
Quite frankly, >> the Heritage Foundation then decided
to agreed with him. I don't know, maybe that doesn't directly
contradict what he's saying here because he's not saying that
you shouldn't platform Nick Fuentes. He's saying that the problem
was that Tucker invited him on and then essentially agreed with
him.
That's I don't believe that's what Ben said because that's not
what happened in the interview. Did Hutch watch the original
interview or you just watching the Ben Shapiro takedown of that
interview
>> about his uh
takes quite frankly the Heritage Found >> the issue with
the Tucker interview is that Tucker did not push back on some
of the takes. The only one he did push back on was the the blood
guilt one, right? But then he also didn't bring up the other
clips of of Nick being misogynistic, of being racist, all of
thisation then decided to robustly defend that performance. Those
who criticize both Tucker and Heritage aren't cancelling. They
are quite properly drawing a moral line. So for those who don't
understand what's going on, let's begin with Nick Fuentes. Now,
as I mentioned last week, Tucker Carlson had on Nick Fuentes.
Fuentes is a 27-year-old man who's dubbed himself the leader
of a movement called the Gropers. He has a large audience of
Sorry, I'm just looking at um >> alienated young white
men in partic. >> Oh, you can't do that at the same time.
What's that all about?
>> I'm just trying to look at the uh the the replies as
No, you can't do it. Okay, never mind. >> Increased media
attention over the course of the past few years, especially over
the last year. Now, from Tucker Carlson's interview, you might
have gathered that Fentes has some borderline views on race,
a peculiar obsession with what he calls organized jewelry, and
a rather sad relationship with the females. But probably you
came away thinking that for the most part >> devastating
night for them. >> Oh my god. Hold on. I just clicked away.
H brutal. >> We're gonna go messaging and
>> draw moral lines between viewpoints. >> Crack
fox. Did I get you for the primer? Thank you, buddy. >> In
fact, we used to call that one of the key aspects of conservatism.
>> Now, Ben is kind of used
>> himself the leader of a movement called the Gropers.
He has a large audience of
>> Here we go. Sorry, I'm just looking at >> alienated
young white men in partic >> Oh, you can't do that at the
same time. What's that all about?
>> I'm just trying to look at the uh the the replies as
I'm >> No, you can't do it. Okay, never mind. >> Open
another tab. >> Increased media attention over the course
of the past few years, especially over the last year. Now, from
Tucker Carlson's interview, we have gathered that Fentes has
some borderline views on race, a peculiar obsession with what
he calls organized jewelry, and a rather sad relationship with
a female. But probably you came away thinking that for the most
part Fuentes lives on the radical edge of normality.
You think that if you watch the >> I don't understand why
are they not uh live streaming Crooked Con. >> Hassan,
final thought. >> Um yeah, we got to get rid of the gerontocracy
within the party >> down with the seniority structure that
we have. >> We need we need real >> whit don't these
guys know? Hold on. Isn't this like the the head of the bull
work? Like the top three most popular channels on YouTube for
leftwing politics, leftwing liberal politics.
Why does he not know that Hassan shocked his dog? Why is he on
a stage with Hassan, this animal abusing monster?
Is he unaware that Hassan has has shocked Ka? Oh my god. >> Whips
in the party. This is something that I talk to you about. This
is something I talk to the P Johns about every single time. If
you have people who don't want to play ball, >> what kind
of whips? like you know it.
>> Don't I don't >> like whipping votes. I don't
mean it in the unless unless it's it's Joe Mansion in which case,
you know, maybe [laughter] I'm kidding. Of course, I can't use
spicy language here, but we need to we need to make sure [laughter]
>> Dutch is trying so hard to make this >> that we
earn the trust of the working class back. And I think that they
have been hyperfocused on culture war narratives. And the only
reason why they've been hyperfocused on culture war narratives
is because we have not done enough on the left flank to say no,
we are with you. We will fight for you. We're going to make sure
that we solve your economic hardships. When he says that the
Democratic Party has been hyperfocused on culture war issues,
I legitimately have no idea what he's talking about. Does anyone
know what he's talking about? Was Joe Biden hyperfocused on culture
war issues? Were these like various Democratic camp? >> What
was the what was the biggest attack on Joe Biden in the 2020
primary? Hutch came from Camala Harris.
What was that over? I forget. Was it over like, "Hey, you're
a racist old who worked with uh
Is that was that the line? Hey, you I I like was it I had to
go on the bus, the segregated bus or something? It was a busing
thing, right? I can't remember. It was something about busing
laws.
Yeah. Oh, she was a black girl who got to go to the white schools.
Okay. I don't know. I just the the connotation of the attack,
although I don't remember it, was you're a racist. You're a racist
candidates
in 2024 and 2025 hyperfocused on culture war issues.
>> No, but they also didn't disavow a lot of their old
positions from the culture war issues they engaged in in 2020,
like
What the is he talking about? Obviously, we're going to have
a
uh I
uh he said, "Was Biden focused on culture war issues?" So, I
gave an example of basically from Biden's first campaign a culture
war issue that came
Um I do think I do think there are like other examples. I don't
think they focused on it. I think they had old culture war issues
that they refused to disavow their positions on, specifically
Kamla, right? People would bring up how she's like obsessed with
trans over and over and she wouldn't say, "Oh, no. I' I've totally
like changed on those positions." She never would say it. She'd
just ignore it, right? Used against them in your example. So,
that's a Dem politician who is utilizing culture war issues in
the Dem primary.
Yes. Dem party politician.
Obviously, an important politician who became VP and then was
the next presidential nominee. who's very much engaged in culture
war issues. Yes. Okay. >> A lot of to watch on Sunday
as I assume they're going to post these panels on their YouTube
page and we can react to it. But I have no idea what the [__]
he's talking about. Does anybody know what he's talking about?
I have no >> The interview. >> Oh yeah. Katanji Brown
Jackson.
Why was Katanji Brown Jackson picked? I forget. Does anybody
know off the top of their head? Was it like a culture war type
of thing? Cuz I remember feeling like it was. Was it like placing
identity above credentials in in many ways? I totally >> because
Tucker Carlson decided that it was important not only to host
Fuentes but to smooth over his views, water them down, and make
them far more palatable to a normal audience. As we'll discuss
in a bit, this is what Tucker Carlson does for a living. But
back to Nick Flynn. Now, I will say I do probably agree with
Hutch that um I don't think well agree with him in that I don't
think Dems were hyperfocused on culture war issues
in the same way, but I do believe there was leftover like momentum
from that that affected their decisions affected Yeah. made them
make poor decisions on things and that their refusal to disavow
old positions was used against them. Yep. says to understand
just what Tucker did here, we must actually examine what Nick
Fuentes says on his >> if I if you've if you're on the
record with a position
and I say you have this position and you never engage with that,
you're going to have to deal with the fact that I'm sticking
that I'm putting that position on you and you won't engage with
it and say you don't have it anymore. Right? So Trump will say
these people want trans surgeries for kids or something and people
won't come out and say no, no, we're against that.
If you never disavow it, it certainly looks suspicious. No. When
when people put that on Trump when they say, "Hey, why won't
you disavow David Duke or something?" And then he doesn't do
it. He refuses to do it. Does that not look suspicious? Does
that not look like, "Oh, I think he actually likes David >> Apparently,
there was a moment between Megan Kelly and uh Bench. >> Uh
I literally don't know one to other than that they were conservative
because Trump didn't say identity reasons for picking them as
far as I know. Unfortunately for you and for Katanji Brown Jackson,
Biden decided he was going to specifically say, "I'm going to
pick somebody of this identity group, this this cross-section
of identity," which is a stupid thing to do. Shapiro just recently
>> for example, Candace Owens, I think that what Candace
Owens is doing right now is evil. It is evil what she is doing
right now. Okay. And I say that again, >> but what what
>> like I I didn't know pine on whether it's evil or not,
but my my position is it's really none of my business. And >> why
is it But I have a question. Why is it none of your business?
I mean, you you you comment on these things for a >> I'm
not mother of the internet. >> No, but but if this were
on the left and >> do you care about He's talking about
your political movement, Megan. How is she so dumb? Like she's
not dumb. She's a lawyer. You know, she got a law degree. I don't
know how she's so aloof and stupid in so many of these clips
that I see. And I don't think it's >> Does Megan Kelly
feel like Candace Owens is a part of her political movement?
>> It's an act. Like I think she's genuinely aloof on a
lot of these things. Um,
he means the working class are focused on culture war issues,
not the Dems.
He just had two ambiguous groups he could be referring to. Did
I misunderstand him? Are you sure? Hold on. Let me just I know
we're getting a little add right >> That doesn't make any
sense. you. I guess you might be right, but Oh god. Where the
[__] is that clip now? >> That's why she's
refraining from commenting. She said she didn't know. She said
she hasn't been watching what Candace is doing. That's why she's
refraining. That's why she's not commenting. She said she was
unaware of >> Crooked
crooked
crooked media. >> Final thought.
>> Um yeah, we got to get rid of the gerontocracy within
the party down with the seniority structure that we have. >> Oh
god, Tim Miller.
I need to see this conversation cuz I know Tim Miller was not
going to sit there and abide.
Where's the full thing for this? Is it online anywhere?
This was yesterday. Cuz you can kind of see it in his face here
too. Like Tim doesn't hide his disdain very well. You think Tim
Miller has disdain for the comment we need to get rid of the
I feel I feel like almost certainly Tim Miller has described
that as a problem. Basically, every single Dem under the age
of 70 that I've seen has described that as a problem. Hey, our
leadership's really old. Hey, our leadership's really old. Hey,
our leadership's really old.
>> I would love to see a conversation between Tim Miller
and Hassan [__]
Um, where the f where the are they broadcasting this to? I don't
understand. You saw this live. Where what do you mean you saw
it live? Where where are they streaming this to? I have to see
Tim Miller and Hassan [__] go back and forth cuz
I'm assuming Oh, you're at the event. How the [__]
do I watch the panels, bro? This is the worst
media convention I've ever heard of. Uh, do you have to go to
their website?
Why is it so hard for me to find these?
>> Crooked me. >> It seems like they haven't released
them yet, right?
So, this is all this is John Favro. This is all the Pod Save
America guys. Let's see.
Can I see? Jeez. Why is this website so dog? Holy sh Look at
this website. This website's garbage. Oh, it just didn't have
a big I don't even know what the was going on there, dude. It
like it it's like a dynamically scaling website. Okay. And it
went to some mode that just doesn't work. The [__]
Let's see. Why don't I see any of the con stuff? Crooked con.
Get tickets. Qriket Con
lineup, schedule, sponsors, program, frequently asked questions.
will there be a lactation/n nursing room? Is that really a frequently
asked question? Yes, there will be a lactation/n nursing room
at Cricutcon. If you need access to this room, please ask someone
at check-in or crooked a crooked volunteer for help. Listen.
And on that note, guys, I've hit 0 0 on the timer
and I'm kind of hit like a a pause anyway.
I'm gonna head her out for the night. Is that bad? No. I just
don't understand. Is that really a frequently asked question?
Like, is there security at Qriket Con? Will there be food and
drink offered? Will there be a lactation room?
I feel like there's a Blizzard employee involved in coordinating
this event. And they they put this question on here explicitly
just to let women know, don't bring your own stuff. There will
be a room. Is that bad? I'm literally joking about it. You
Anyway, have a good night, guys. Gonna host uh who here?
Oh, basically nobody online. Resi probably. Have a good night.
Talk to you later. Bye-bye.